e e
they were
saying e
good morning everybody and welcome to
environment agriculture
committee are any committee members in
the hallway I'd like to get
started know thank
you thank you okay thank you I'd like
members to take their seat
please and I would like to have
representative Kenny lead us in the
Pledge of Allegiance
please to the flag of the United States
of America and to the Republic for which
it stands one nation under God
indivisible with liberty and
justice thank you so much
they can't go
yeah okay uh we have a hearing this
morning uh for HB
566 I don't I left my gab at home so I
get this really Nifty piece of wood to
knock on courtesy of Representative
Spain so I'm going to open the hearing
this morning for HB 566 requiring permit
applications for new landfills to
contain a detailed plan for leech 8
management and here to introduce the
bill is representative ger good morning
representative German thank you makes
you legal your pink
card if anybody wishes to speak please
um make sure you have a pink
card and I also like to remind committee
members that uh for for our purpose in
these hearings is to receive
testimony if we have questions on what
the person has said that's fine but we
want to um make sure we are not arguing
back and forth we are not uh with with
the person testifying that we are not
um uh asking leading questions we are
just here to listen to what people have
to say regarding the legislation before
US Representative Bixby would you like
to add anything to that um yeah I I
think that one of the things that we can
do in order to make our our process a
little bit more efficient is uh pay
attention to if you if you hear uh a
witness provide an answer to a question
and it's clear that that is what they
are you know what they think is in fact
the case uh don't ask the same question
again in a different way because you're
not going to get a different
answer um so uh think about um what's
your think about what's going to get the
most information out the most
efficiently don't try to
um and if the answer if the if a
question really has been answered don't
um just don't reiterate it
thank you I also want to inform uh
committee members that I have to
introduce a bill in election law at 20
after 10 so uh I will leave the
committee in the capable hands of our
vice chair representative ktoa and with
that I would like to begin our hearing
and good morning representative gerana
good morning thank you madam chair
honorable colleagues uh I don't have
written testimony but I did pass around
a document uh should be enough copies
for everybody and two for the clerk that
I'll be referring to during my uh
introduction so the the origin of this
bill regarding uh plans for leech eight
management and transportation I think
we're all aware of reporting uh over the
last year about problems with management
of lee8 and uh
Transportation at some of the landfills
here in New Hampshire uh last July there
was an article in New Hampshire bulletin
about
um infractions I quote hundreds of uh
infractions hundreds of times that uh
cassella at their their Bethlehem
facility failed to keep leachate to its
required levels and to file mandatory
reports that uh article from the
bulletin in July also referred to at
least three other facilities in the
state that received letters citing
deficiencies associated with lee8
management uh and so this bill is a very
bipartisan bill as you can see from the
sponsorship uh uh we have worked with
the Department of Environmental Services
I've also spoken with uh Mr POI from uh
the turnkey facility in Rochester to try
to better understand uh how they deal
with leech eight at that
facility uh I'll be speaking in a moment
to some specific changes that uh I think
I will be coming forward with an
amendment based on conversations with uh
the experts at Dees and the and the
folks at at TurnKey but uh I I think
it's clear that we recognize that this
is a problem in the state as you said
that that article last summer made it
clear that uh there are a number of
facilities and some facilities with
literally citing hundreds of potential
violations we need to address this
concern particularly as we become more
and more aware of the dangers of pasas
these uh this leachate this uh so-called
uh trash juice is filled with these
materials they are disposed of
ultimately through our wastewater
treatment uh plants and uh so the danger
to Public Health both in terms of
potential onsite problems potential
Transportation issues but also as we
consider how they are ultimately
disposed of this is an issue that a
bipartisan group of our legislature has
come together to
address with the increased frequency and
severity of rainstorms that we've seen
you know once in a century floods every
three to five years over the past few
years we are seeing uh larger and larger
quantities of leech eight being produced
at these facilities and that is part of
the reason why we're in the problem uh
that we are in is because the plans for
leech a management did not when they
were uh these facilities were brought
into operation they were not designed
for the amount and severity of the
rainstorms that we've been getting so
they're not adequately prepared in many
cases is to be able to deal with the
amount of leech a that's being produced
at these facilities so um again that is
one of the driving motives behind this
legislation is the recognition uh that
with the increased severe weather we've
had that we need to be much more mindful
about how we are managing leate on site
at transporting it and ultimately seeing
it uh disposed of I want to speak very
briefly to one of the objections that
were already seen about uh potential
concerns that this would somehow uh be a
problem for businesses that this would
hamper the ability ability of businesses
to innovate obviously what we know about
p is changing methods for treating P are
changing rapidly businesses certainly
need to be able to come up with new
methods for treating the leech a turnkey
does some really interesting uh a couple
of different ways that they
pre-treat their lee8 before it is
transported actually through pipes
rather than trucks to a facility a
Wastewater facility so we need that
Innovation this bill does not in any way
hamper Innovation this simply says when
you're applying for a a permit I'm going
to talk about the language a little bit
in a minute when you're applying for a
permit you have to have a plan a
detailed plan for how you're going to
manage the leech a on site how you are
going to transport that leech a offsite
and a a recognition that you have some
responsib ility for making sure that it
is disposed of in a safe way on the
other side it doesn't
dictate how that has to be done it says
nothing at all about specific methods of
doing these things which would uh you
know instantiate in statute requirements
that could hamper Business Development
none of that uh and there is a passage
in the second paragraph of this bill
which says very clearly uh when you
change you have new contracts for
example uh for transportation or uh or
disposal the leech 8 you simply have to
then report those new contracts uh it
doesn't as you said in any way restrict
the content of those contracts it simply
says that when you enter into new
agreements those new agreements have to
be reported as part of the plan that is
provided to the
department so what I've distributed to
you all is
a um it's not a formal uh draft of an
amendment it's some new language that I
wanted to share with you all and
depending on uh how our conversation
goes uh you know sending this to OS to
have as an amendment for when we do a
work session or an executive session but
uh some of these changes that you see in
the handout that I provided are the
result of the conversations I've had
with uh Mike whimet uh and uh with Mr
POI from uh waste management at TurnKey
so if you look at uh the bill itself the
the page that has State of New Hampshire
at at the top unfortunately I apologize
that the uh photocopy that you all
received that kind of highlighted
portions are very very difficult to see
they got kind of uh washed out in the
the photo copy if you look very very
hard you can faintly see outlines but
I'll point to them uh in this text and
if you look at the other side of the
bill uh you will see the specific
references that are were highlighted uh
on on the first side the bill as you can
see has two paragraphs the first
paragraph is about a leech eight
management plan to say that when you're
applying for uh a permit and again I'm
going to speak about that language you
have to have a plan that plan contains
certain elements About Management
transportation and Disposal for the
lifetime of the facility including post
closure period the second paragraph
contains some specific language around
contracts that operators would have with
companies again for disposal or uh or
Transportation or or
disposal when I met with director whims
uh and spoke to the folks at at TurnKey
about their operation uh it became clear
in the bill as it is written there's
some language in that second
paragraph specifically about long-term
contracts
uh that is inappropriate for that
section of the bill we can't under you
know completely understandably we can't
require these facilities to be able to
demonstrate that they have contracts 20
or 30 years down the road obvious that
that's not how it works uh and I
appreciate that feedback so what we did
is we removed some of that language from
the contractual paragraph the second
paragraph and we put that up the plan is
to move it up to the first paragraph
right so that it is not required in
terms of demonstrating a a contract that
contains these things uh but instead to
say that your plan when you submit for a
permit must contain details about how
you plan to deal with these things
um so if you if you see my summary of
proposed
changes I'll walk you through very
briefly just five changes all of the
language from the bill you have in front
of you is there it's been moved around
and it's been adjusted in a couple of
cases so after discussion with
Dees uh I think it makes sense to change
the phrase permit for construction to
operating approval that is as I
understand it a more accurate reflection
of the permitting
process number two at the suggestion of
Dees an amendment that uh I would plan
would include expansions of landfills
they said that that was as far as they
were concerned entirely consistent with
what they do and anyway how they would
evaluate applications for expansions of
landfills third this has to do with that
language that was moved out of the
contract section up into the section
requiring a
plan the uh the language throughout the
entire life of the facility including
the post closure period has been moved
as I said from the contractual
requirement section up to the details of
the lee8 management plan
likewise number four the language
regarding frequency of shipments and
details of contingency plans has also
been moved into the section on the leech
8 management plan obviously again these
are things that uh by their nature
contingencies things change business
relationships change uh we can't require
all of those things over a long period
of time in contract but we need to make
sure number one that they are in the
plan from the beginning and number two
that when changes are made in those
contracts that they are subsequently
submitted to
Dees uh and finally there is a section
at the bottom uh the new subp paragraph
uh this I think is likely to be removed
because uh upon discussion with uh
director whimet um I think some of the
other changes above actually removed the
necessity for adding uh this paragraph
in particular especially that change uh
regarding op operating approval uh that
phrase so uh that is an overview of the
bill I hope I have explained it in a way
that makes sense uh and and also in a
way that allows uh you to see how the
changes keep the purpose and the
language of the original bill but uh
after consultation uh have probably
something that we would want to do thank
you madam chair thank you so much
representative ger and um I I appreciate
I want to tell you I appreciate the work
that you've done and the collaboration
you've done with the Department uh on
this bill uh to bring it to us in a u
more workable more understandable form
and uh I appreciate your time and your
work on that representative Bixby you
had a question yeah I have it's just a
clarifying question since uh since the
highlighting didn't come through I just
want to make sure that when you what
you're talking about is what's being
deleted is from line 20 to line
23 yes that's correct representative
thank you thank you representative
Miner thank you madam chairman and thank
you uh representative one question I
have is so you're saying that Waste
Management has in place this uh this
leeching uh um um information available
to us but gella doesn't is that correct
in saying that am I correct in saying
that
no I thank you for the question I don't
believe uh that's the case by rule right
now a number of these things are already
required uh and are overseen and that's
you know for example that article
referred to actions that kind of Dees
has taken with regard to a number of
operators in the State uh so uh I
believe that uh Dees has this
information uh on you know from all of
the operators thank
you any other questions from the
committee representative King thank you
madam chair and thank you representative
for testifying on this bill um what
recourse is there if if any that if the
plan that is provided in order to get
the permit later falls through you know
they don't they don't follow through on
their plan or something happens where
oops we didn't quite pull it off like we
thought we would that's kind of my
concern is yeah you you had a but you
didn't execute and now the water table's
been poisoned what do you say about that
thank you that's an excellent question
thank you very much and I would defer on
some of the details to to Dees I don't
know if they're they're here if we have
some folks great uh on some of those
details uh excellent thank you uh but my
understanding is that first of all we
have to think about the relationship
between these operators and Dees is an
ongoing conversation so when it comes to
monitoring the plans and whether or not
the plans are being being implemented I
think that's part of an ongoing
relationship between Dees and operators
uh Dees also has the ability again that
and I can provide this specific citation
to the committee that article from July
refers to letters and and actually has
links to certain letters that Dees wrote
to some of the operators in the state
about deficiencies in their uh their
management of of leech a so that's part
of an ongoing process and then when
there are violations as there there have
been as I said Dees can speak to the
specific uh mechanisms that they use to
uh to have
enforcement representative Howard thank
you madam chair um in this letter that
we just got from the Bia um and thanks
representative J for putting together
such a great idea um they they mentioned
that regulation um might uh what do they
say instituting a statutory approach
there is serious risk of stat statutory
parameters turning into restraints on
Innovation and I'm just wondering if uh
if the plans are
are you know just can't be expanded
after thank you very much for that
question Representatives so so two
things number one as I as I mentioned
before there is nothing in this bill
that is going to stifle uh Innovation
right again when new contracts are
entered into
as new technologies develop uh though
that information can just be forwarded
to Dees right so there's nothing that
locks them into any particular method or
any particular contract so I don't see
where the argument comes from that
Innovation is uh is being stifled uh as
to the first part of that question uh I
will only say that I worked closely with
Dees to craft the language especially in
in the amendment that I plan to put
forward and Dees has told myself and
representative eel who attended that
meeting that they see this as a valuable
tool that goes hand inand with what
currently exists in rules so uh we have
worked hard to make sure that this isn't
simply a dup duplication of what's in
rules but that it is in fact an effort
to put something in statute that helps
Dees Implement rules in a more effective
way
followup thank you um is there is there
any any way to write into the language
um increasing the plan or changing the
plan to um re respond to failure of the
plan I think I will punt on that to to
Dees because I think it is connected to
representative King's question about how
Dees uh relates to these operators and
and what the consequences would be if a
company fails to adhere to its plan so I
think Dees can speak to that better than
I
can anybody else have questions
seeing n thank you representative Jama
and I'd like to call Notch
Grace thank you madam chair n Grace for
the business and industry Association uh
I appreciate you all taking the time to
look at the letter that I handed out
earlier today um so let me just start
off by saying we do uh oppose this bill
as it has been introduced to you based
on
the representatives prior testimony it
sounds like there's going to be a
substantial rewrite so I'd certainly uh
like to have the opportunity to take a
look at that and see how that would
affect um our position um but one thing
that I would like to point out which is
not in the letter but which I thought of
uh as the testimony proceeded this
morning was simply asking the question
of whether this legislation was
necessary um I think there was a
reference to a article in the New
Hampshire bulletin um which cites uh New
Hampshire Dees issuing a number of
letters of deficiency and taking a look
at those letters they cite specific
Provisions within the EnV uh 86 rules uh
and basically said hey operator you're
doing things wrong so there already
rules in place that regulate these areas
and the point of the letters is
obviously to induce The Operators to
make Chang changes to uh manage leate in
a different manner
so um based on the description of the
forthcoming Amendment um and the ability
of operators to Simply alter the
contracts you know imagine a scenario
where I'm an
operator or I I would like to be an
operator um so I submit a plan to Dees
and then I can just go and change a
contract a month later so what's the
point of that um is kind of my question
um it seems that to me that a better
option is to allow the administrative
rules to continue what they normally
continue which is give Dees authority to
regulate uh this particular area um
refine kind of what the federal federal
uh pering rules are as well
and as part of that process
um assist operators uh if and when um
issues arise um that's certainly part of
de's technical assistance um it's
something they can do in a Nimble
fashion within the rule framework which
is much harder to do in the statute if
you were to put this in statute because
in statute they'd have to come back to
the legislature make changes rather than
um take a look at their existing rules
or write their rules in a manner that
allows them to look at things like new
Innovative products for treatment of
pasas um you know as as we learn more
about that as operators experiment with
you know what could we do to pre-treat
leate before it goes to the wastewater
treatment facility um you know is
something like a resin solution going to
work is something like a carbon based
solution going to work is it going to be
the case that Ro filters are the best
option as they really narrow that down
um Dees has that Authority within their
their current regulatory framework and
certainly they could rewrite uh the rule
the rules if necessary um to allow them
to do that as other states have done uh
to help address uh new and emerging um
issues that arise out of leech Aid
management um as well as of course
provide technical assistance for Best
Practices um so I just don't I think you
know although I haven't seen the
language for the substantial rewrite of
the amendment I believe it's the case
that our position would be to continue
to oppose it based on the fact that it's
simply not necessary
happy to take
questions representative Bixby yes thank
you for taking my
question so uh the way I'm reading the
bill it is essentially requiring that
when a landfill is being planned it is
that uh that part of that planning has
to uh requires Advanced planning for how
lee8 is going to be managed and that's
going to be something that that gets
built in the INF infrastructure of the
landfill but it also looks like uh the
the way that it's phrased here it allows
for updating as requirements um you you
mentioned contracts um so uh this is
this is a plan for like 30 years so
you're not going to be able to plan your
contracts for 30 years of course so it
leaves that it seems like leaves that
um that Avenue still open for changing
contracts as you need to so I'm not
quite sure uh how this is going to be um
if you have if you have if it gives a
lot of leeway for discussion between the
department and the and the operator I'm
not could you explain a little bit more
how that is going to be uh uh limiting
the operator's
Freedom well the department and the
operator already have the the
opportunity to have that discussion and
Lee's already a managed I'm going to
call it an item but Ma trash juice is
already managed right so it's not like
you can start up a landfill and just you
know dump it into the river that's not
the process there's a whole regulatory
framework laid out under the 806 rules
about how you treat this so as you plan
a new landfill you already have to look
at the rules and you already have to
have in place uh you know a plan uh
engineering engineering design um and
then in response to what's actually
happy on the landfill you have to make
adjustments as that goes which is going
to require discussion with Dees under
their existing rules so again I I'm not
sure what this legislation adds
to the regulatory framework other than
to you know freeze it in place and
obviously as we've heard from earlier
testimony there are some concerns about
the bill is introduced and the language
uh as introduced um causing an
interpretation to be that you have to
have something like you know a 50-year
contract which simply I think everybody
recognizes is not doable followup yes so
um I'm I'm not quite sure where the uh
where this changes the relationship with
the rules other than just clarifying how
the rules will go forward
so to build off your question
representative I'm not sure how this
changes the rules other than it
constrains uh the the current rul making
process in in a manner which again I
haven't seen the amendment I don't know
if that's something that the uh
committee would be amendable to
um that constrains the ability of Dees
to adopt rules that reflect uh what
they're actually seeing thank you
representative Howard then
representative
Penza thank you madam chair um so the
way I see it is that this this bill
would establish a starting point or a
commitment to uh to a plan and um and if
if we wait to make rules that respond to
conditions that have already say gone
bad then the horse is out of the barn so
it seems like this this amend this um
bill will help us to establish a
commitment to dealing with leech a in
the best possible
way so my response to that would be as I
understood it the reason for this
legislation was because of an article in
the New Hampshire bulletin citing Dees
letters of
deficiency based on existing rules
so again there already rules in place
why do we need this
legislation represent
Penza so I have two questions if I thank
you madam chair um thank you for your
testimony so would you would you think
that a thousand violations in a row be
evidence uh in these letters that
they're not effective in changing
Behavior I can't speak
to uh you know the process of
enforcement at the departmental level I
what I would say is
that you know uh attempting but not
capturing the existing rules to rewrite
them in a different place is not
necessarily going to change uh how those
you know what what people do with
those followup thank you madam chair so
are you familiar with the current Rule
now um environment
80653 that requires no less than two
locations for Le trate treatment or
disposure shall be available by written
agreement to manage the quantity of
leate generated by the facility during
its active life and then it you've got
further I've got a question
um because basically your your testimony
is contradicting this bill doesn't set
newa it just sets the guard rails for
that are you familiar with these are
already in place like the leate stuff
that you already have to do is already
in place it's not changing that it's
just putting some parameters thank you
representative uh Penza that's um
exactly the point that I'm trying to
make is there's no reason uh this bill
is entirely unnecessary if it the entire
purpose of it is to Simply move the
rules into State Statute Dees already
has the rules in place they've adopted
rules uh as far as I'm aware they work
well um and they certainly uh Garner
public
attention representative Willer thank
you madam chair thank you for taking my
question would you say that Dees rules
are more or less
what's the word I want to use protected
more or less uh long-term than a state
statute is but I mean wouldn't you say a
state statute is more affirmative of
what the state is actually trying to do
around those rules and if there's a
presented problem such as a thousand
instances of such a thing happening a
state statute would be more impactful
than Dees rules
if I understood the correctly if I
understood the question correctly
representative wheeler uh you're asking
me whether I think that uh a state
statute uh is longer lasting than uh the
agency
rules um my understanding is that
generally the legislature grants
agencies the authority to write rules
because they recognize the technical
experts that the agency uh are in the
best position to assess uh really the
technical aspect specs as well as new
Innovations coming forward and adjust
those those rules if proper over time um
so rather than having to come back to
the legislature uh and go through a
legislative process uh the rul making
process can occur at the agency level
among those technical experts with
stakeholders um they are having
input followup
yes I appreciate that now wouldn't it be
true that in some instances say for
instance uh I don't know trash juice is
leeching out and poisoning the land of
the state that it's maybe prudent for
the legislature to take a step forward
and put those rules into statute or you
know there are instances where Dees and
the technical expertise of the
organization should create those rules
and then there are other instances where
the public health is so profoundly
affected that the legislature and the
representative should do something where
do you think that line is well given
that the 806 rules exist and they've
gone through the jail car process
therefore uh seen approval by the
legislature they've been in place for a
long period of time um what I would say
is that it seems like it's the
legislature's policy that Dees should
regulate leech 8 um and the agency
appears to be doing
that okay representative H Haskins thank
you madam chair good morning Nate
morning would you agree that the state
has a leech a
problem I don't know that I would be
qualified to judge that representative
okay um if I may second question y so is
it your understanding that the
legislature makes the rules makes the
law and that the agency writes the
rules representative that the way I
would frame it is the legislature sets
the general policy regulate lee8 the
agency goes out through the rul making
process has created the 806 rules that's
what we have in place right now um and
it's my belief that those those work
well thank you okay representative
Howard hi so again um so the again the
way that I see it the the laws and the
rules are conceptual they they the
concept of controlling leech a is is
defined in the rules and in the law and
the plan is a is a detailed and
specific approach but at that site by
that that by that um P
purveyor that would that would answer
the rules the the concept that would
fill the concept in that at that place
by that person or that by that
company so so there's it's there's a set
there's is is do you see a difference
between the rules and the actual plan as
you know as a fulfillment of the
concept I'm not sure I entirely
understood the question representative
Howard but I would do my best to respond
um you know because the 806 rules exist
anyone who wants to open a new landfill
in the state would have to keep account
of those rules along with any additional
rules applicable to them uh along with
obviously any state statutes permitting
Etc at the state Federal level
um in their entire engineering for that
facility um so it would already be the
case that
they're that they're taking account of
this so again there's no need to add
additional statute to this because it
doesn't actually add anything to
what potential new operators are doing
um at best it's repetitive at worst it
interferes with or would create a
conflict with existing rules or
potential future rules based on uh you
know new technologies coming online or
based on you know new requirements uh
you know maybe the impossibility of
certain contractional language Etc um
and so the only thing that ends up doing
is is gumming up the works as uh
businesses try to figure out you know
what are the rules that I'm supposed to
follow because I
I have a state statute plus I have these
rules um and we're also come we're also
hearing from you know other other
industry players you know here's some
new Innovative technology like example
uh pfast treatment it's working really
well in some other state we want to
bring it in you know it may be the case
and I'm not an expert at New Hampshire's
rules but it may be the case that you
know like in Vermont uh our our agency
could say yep we're going to go through
our permitting process make some slight
adjustments so we can have that as a
potential use here um whereas if we're
in State Statute we're stuck and we have
to come back to the
legislature uh you know get permission
from the legislature which then would
require the agency to rewrite the rules
and you're you're taking this long
process instead of uh really shortening
it up which allows you know treatment of
something like past to occur in a faster
manner representative Miner thank you
madam chairman one quick question do you
see this this to be a burden on um on
the industry as opposed to um what it
actually does in my opinion is um give
us more in-depth look at what's going on
in the um in the uh
leeet thank you for the question uh yes
we would consider this a burden on the
industry um because again you'd be
setting up this whole another regulatory
framework even though one already exists
followup thank thank
you this in my again in my opinion this
seems to clarify what's already written
do you agree with that statement I do
not thank you okay any other questions
from the committee seeing none thank you
for your testimony this morning I'd like
to call Tom
Tower from Whitefield representing North
Country
ABC welcome Mr Tower you've asked for
three minutes
good morning everyone um there's been so
much discussion around the article in
the New Hampshire bulletin I thought I'd
take the opportunity to pass it around I
think it's informative and and probably
a good idea that if you can to to uh
take a look at it
um first of all Madam chair nice to see
you presiding over this committee again
and all the familiar faces that uh we've
spoken to over the years it's nice to
see you for those people that I have not
met and for the record my name is Tom
Tower and I uh live in Whitefield New
Hampshire and I'm here also uh
representing North Country Alliance for
balance
change um I'd like to than that uh that
every bill that comes before you know
this
committee uh is important um and I've
seen an awful lot of them over the years
um but not all of them are urgent
this one is
urgent and I'm going to take uh just a
minute to read a few of the passages
that are in that New Hampshire bulletin
piece which I think will further
exemplify why we feel this is urgent so
representative ger spoke about uh a
situation that occurred in Bethlehem and
in that particular facility Lee is
pumped off the liner where it travels
through pipes and onto a storage tank
before getting trucked off the facility
and treated from the second half of 2021
to the first half of 2023 the landfill
pumped out 2.8 million gallons of lee8
per quarter that's skyrocketed from the
second half of 2023 to the beginning of
2024 to 5.2 million gallons per
quarter by rule landfills are also
required to have systems in place to
prevent more than 12 Ines of lee8 from
being stored on the liner on hundreds of
occasions between July 2023 and June
2024 the Bethlehem facility failed to
keep to that required level and in one
instance that level was 11
16.42% be any higher than 12 in because
when it does go higher than 12 in it
puts an undue amount of stress on that
infrastructure and could potentially
lead to a
disastrous uh issue of contamination and
certainly uh past
contamination HB
566 addresses a regulatory Gap requiring
detailed planning for the backend
including transportation and wastewater
treatment the plans do not include that
today today it's primarily collection
and storage does this put an undue
burden I shouldn't say undue but does it
Place additional burdens on an applicant
well yes it does yes it does but at the
same time the benefits of health and uh
the the benefits to local economy
surrounding these areas that are
potentially contaminated are
incomparable and I I am happy to take
any questions thank you Mr Tower any
questions from the representative Bixby
yes so um thank you madam chair and uh
thank you Mr tower for coming in uh so
do uh am I correct in in understanding
your testimony as saying that the
advantage of uh this bill over existing
rules as is that this bill actually
covers the entire life cycle of the
leate process as opposed to just the
front end of it that is correct in life
cycle it certainly can't be on in F item
but there's already been amendments to
uh clarify the fact that you couldn't
put mechanisms in place or contracts say
Beyond a 20year horizon I haven't seen
the amendment but yes that is correct
representative Bixby thank you any other
questions thank you Mr Tower appreciate
you coming today thank you committee um
Mr Wayne Morrison also from North
Country ABC you've asked for five
minutes but if something's already been
said that you've heard please uh refrain
from repeating
it
welcome Mike there you
go you may want me to turn it off
I came this far I might as well deliver
um before I I I I I probably won't need
five minutes but I have some written
testimony but I wanted to put my view of
this bill in context before I
started I think this committee certainly
myself uh six years ago when I think of
a landfill I think of trash haulers I
think of a mountain of trash I think of
odors scavenger Birds you know noise
that's the part of the land landfill
that I
understood um and I had no view I had no
insight into the invisible part of the
dangers of a landfill which is uh
lee8 and although we are deeply
concerned about you know protecting the
environment and our our
water um I have come to learn that leech
eight is a much greater risk to our
health and our safety than that mountain
of trash that we can all see very
visibly I don't know if you know it or
not uh but landfills generate an
incredible volume a staggering amount of
this
leachate it's my understanding that in
the the six landfills that we have in
the state of New Hampshire produce
something north of 100 million gallons
of Lee shade every
year that's an unbelievable amount that
has to be dealt with and lee8 um as you
may know is a
cocktail of heavy metals toxins
P um and the process that we have today
the best available system we have today
is all of that leech a in one form or
another is either trucked or piped to a
municipal solid waste facility and if
everything works
perfectly um some of those toxins are
removed and some of them aren't and P
for example either ends up being
concentrated into sludge or bricks that
go back to the landfill or a certain
percentage of it the solution we have
today is to dilute it into our rivers in
many cases the meramac river so
forgetting about spills and leaks and
problems if the system's working
perfectly we have a flawed system to
begin
with to me the reason to even point that
out the volume of this stuff is
is I think the legislature needs to
stand up and and make a policy position
on this stuff I am guessing that your
constituents near those wastewater
treatment plants have no idea what's
being released into the
river I think we need to be prudent
diligent I don't know if this creates a
little bit more work for the
operators but the risk to human health
and to the environment is
great and leech a is is becoming a
greater and greater problem what you
heard earlier
was the climate has changed we are
having more severe
storms it is going to be probably more
and more difficult to predict how much
leech a is going to be generated each
year and we don't have a lot of excess
capacity at our Municipal Solid Waste
facilities I think this is a policy
decision There are rules to today I
would say they're not effective enough
we can't be careful enough with how we
handle this stuff so I would ask the
committee to think hard about um this is
this is risks and benefits to the people
of the state and the downside of a
problem with leech eight is a is a huge
problem and we can't be careful enough
so I think from my my testimony is ncbc
strong L supports this bill the more we
learn about leech 8 the more concerned
we should be and today we don't may
maybe technology will save us maybe we
will figure out a way to remove some of
those toxins but today they're not
totally removed and I would ask the
committee to think hard about how can we
put every Bell and whistle in place to
protect not only the environment but the
health and safety of citizens who today
I'll bet most are unaware of the risk
that that they're under so
we strongly would suggest you support
this
Bill thank you so much um Mr Morrison
yeah I have a question from
representative
Penza thank you madam chair and thank
you so much for coming in with your
testimony um just for the record I think
it's important could you explain um
because I know you know um the process
of when Lee's like leaving let's say uh
NCS in Bethlehem and goes to wastewater
treatment plant um that process how it's
a circular motion and then ends up
coming back into the
landfill yeah so um and again I I I I I
uh I've been on a crash course and
learning about this stuff because you
know it it's complicated but uh you know
leech a in various forms has to be first
collected in the liner then yet
generally stored you know pumped and
stored on tanks and then pumped out of
those tanks into into trucks trucked 100
miles down to either conquer or
Manchester or Franklin or one of the
waste treatment facilities in the
area it goes through a process uh some
of the materials are um collected in
solids and and brought back to the
landfill and the the effluent is then
released um after the processing into
the river so we have a very convoluted
system right I mean if you think about
what's happening in the state um half of
our waste comes from out of state so you
think about the the footprint right
we're driving hundreds of miles up in
the case of ncees to with trash we're
extracting the leech eight and then
going a 100 miles south to the waste
treatment
plants I think what the article that my
colleague uh Tom Tower brought forward
is a you know there were problems and
part of the reason there were problems
was there was capacity issues at the
municipal Solid Waste
facilities I guess that's not cella's
fault it you know they they had to they
didn't have a they didn't have a
solution it is their fault to let
significant amounts of lee8 build up in
the liner system um because that's a big
that's a structural infrastructure
problem the the ler could fail but
whatever whatever happened there's
there's a limited amount of capacity and
it it to me it just
reinforces how we need to be extremely
diligent we need to reduce we need to
move our our efforts towards diversion
and and and and stop bringing so much
you know we got to reduce the amount of
trash and and trash you should think of
trash as leech a they are one and the
same you can't have one without the
other and leech eight is extremely
dangerous and we can't be too
careful thank you any other questions
from the committee seeing none thank you
so much for coming today I'd like to
call John Swan from safe Forest Lake
uh to come and speak you've asked for
three minutes
good
morning good morning Madam chair members
of the committee thank you for taking my
testimony my name is John Swan I'm the
founder of save Force Lake I live in
Dalton New Hampshire um I will try and
be as brief as possible um I do need to
preface my testimony by stating that in
order to not get sued at third time by
cassella Waste Systems I need you to
understand that all of my testimony is
my opinion based on my research my
experience um
I want to say first off I I I did email
um well documented testimony to each of
you I hope you received it I hope you
had a chance to read it I also want to
point out that uh by my Tally online it
looks like
265 uh citizens from New Hampshire
weighed in took time out of their day to
weigh in and supported this so people
realize that obviously in New Hampshire
we have an issue with protecting clean
water as well as posos uh land Phi leech
8 as well as biosolids and land
application as we're seeing what's
happening in Maine but I digress um I
did want to um state that I am not
really a fan of the uh amended version
that I heard at the beginning by uh
representative gerana because partly I'm
concerned that the the fingerprint of
Dees which is part of the problem and
Industry is on this amendment and uh I
I'm not a fan of it furthermore I'd like
to say I do support the bill as
introduced however otpa because I'd like
to see it amended to remove existing
facilities in part because the and once
once GSL has stopped in Dalton and it
will because we we've been at this for
six years we're not going to stop
Governor aot has come out against it but
once that stopped cassella will probably
go back to NCS and Bethlehem to seek an
expansion and I would hate to see they
be exe Exempted from this requirement
since they are kind of the the impetus
for this bill and I had nothing to do
with this bill uh over the course of the
past year I have sent the committee a
lot of documentation relative to the
April 22nd or so April leech eight
emergency at the Bethlehem facility um
in which they had an issue with finding
sources for their lee8 their landfill
leech eight in fact just to clarify um
part of it's not the wastewater
treatment plant's ability to have
capacity to accept the leech it's the
toxicity conquer decided to
limit in early
2024 the intake of NCS landfill lee8
because of the T tox the toxicity of it
um since then uh Manchester was taking
some however I was told they are not
taking it because of the posos in the
lead shap so just a point of
clarification some of the NCS lee8 is
being shipped as far away as Madison
Maine and to um New Jersey so I do want
to get back to my testimony though
because I did in my in my documents I
sent you I sent you a September 24th
2024 letter from the Department a
request for more information to cassella
and CS landfill and in that um the
department the first point they asked
for written agreements of no less than
two locations for leech a treatment or
disposal to manage the quantity of leech
a generated by the facility during its
active of Life consistent with EnV SW
80605 B3 and pursuant to EnV SW
110511 so I did uh furthermore in my
testimony I broke down both of those
80605 B requires two locations for the
active life it's already in the
rules second 110510 B states that um a
facility shall obtain and maintain
access to at least two authorized
locations where adequate capacity exists
to handle the basically residual waste
during its operating and post closure
period so it's already in the rules it's
already in the rules however if the
department comes up and does testify
taking a non-pos on this bill and then
stating why they're opposed to the bill
perhaps you can ask the department why
they are not
enforcing these rules because I have
sent and it's in your packet a 91a right
to no request to the department asking
for a copy of those two written
agreements that they asked for in that
September 24th letter of the NCS
facility and the response I got from the
department and it's in your packet they
have no record of that so right now
there's two rules covering leee there's
no record there's no written agreement
that's what was part of the problem in
April they were shifting around trying
to find people who would take their lee8
as it was raining and and they were
working on stage six Phase 2 etc etc
further more I then asked because we're
talking about a new landfill that's
going to generate it's going to be
bigger than NCS the permitted capacity
life is the the annual permitted
capacity in the permit for GSL is 2.5
times what NCS is currently permitted to
accept 600,000 cubic yards a year versus
2302 200,000 cubic yards a year that's
2.5 times what does that buy GSL with
all that land it buys room for further
permitted capacity life beyond 18 years
because if that is not exhausted they
can continue to operate by my Tally and
I put it in the Forest Lake Landfill
information sheet that I sent you that's
about 46 years of permanent life for GSL
second I asked for written agreements
for lee8 Generation lee8 disposal for
GSL
there are none I got the same response
from Dees they have no written
agreements and I did want to let you
know that in the current permit
applications for the GSL landfill and
Dalton they have already changed who the
wastewater treatment plants that would
accept their leachate in the operating
plan uh removing I can't remember
conquered um but including New Jersey
and Maine so and all of that has to be
Tred it's it's not like it it's not like
TurnKey which is attached to a
wastewater treatment plant or avart up
in uh you know um Success New Hampshire
which is tied into a wastewater
treatment plant all of NCS land fi leate
has to be trucked to a plant same thing
with GSL it's the same concept as NC and
I ask you where is that leachate going
to go if there's no cure for posos
there's no uh wastewater treatment plant
that's going to accept it what happens
that's what we're asking and we've
tested our wells we've tested the lake
we've tested Alderbrook which is what
the wetlands flow into that then flow
into the amonk river we've tested all
that I've done the testing for posos
there's no detections we've tested 39
homes around the vicinity of the GSL
site no detections for peos I've
included that in the testimony I've sent
you at Great expense in time and
furthermore
GSL itself has tested its own monitoring
Wells at the proposed site they have no
detections for posos contamination at
that facility or at that site it's not a
facility yet so hopefully you will do
the right thing we need written
agreements it's already in the rules to
protect New Hampshire again I'm
concerned because Dees is not enforcing
the current rules that are on the books
I feel that an amendment to this bill
needs to be made made and it needs as
representative
wheeler attested to it's going to give
enforcement strength to the rules
requiring these facilities to have a
contract or an agreement so with that I
mean I won't take up any more of your
time I would just say that you
know in 20123 NCS produced 11 million
gallons of Lee a that was in 2023 we
haven't seen the facility report for
2024 that has to be trucked somewhere
who's going to take it and why isn't
Dees enforcing the rules on the books
right now so happy to take any questions
I believe I can provide any answers you
need because I've been studying this for
six years okay thank you Mr Swan
appreciate it you don't see any
questions and thank you for coming this
morning all righty thank you uh last I
have director Michael whimet from New
Hampshire
good
morning morning Madam chair members of
the committee um happy to be before you
this morning for the record my name is
Mike whimet I serve as director of the
waste management division for New
Hampshire Dees um G uh Dees is not
taking a position on this bill um as uh
representative Jam the sponsor has
indicated we've had some discussions at
length about the cont content of this
bill and worked well together to address
uh some some questions that that we had
um I have not actually seen the
amendment but I think I understand its
content based on the representative's
description of it um you know our sense
of this bills that the concerns we had
with relate in relation to the bill is
introduced have largely been addressed
um I think uh in response to some of the
things that have been said here this
morning I think what this adds um by by
by amending the statute to have explicit
language relative to leech 8 management
and the requirement for leech 8
management plan is it it just makes it
more clear and explicit um the including
details of contracts that um that that
folks have for management of leech 8 um
is something that uh the current rules
say you have to have a two at least two
outlets for your leech a but they don't
specify necessarily the details of the
contract so that is a new addition and
uh we we don't have any particular
concerns about that um and then um I
think that it perhaps provides a longer
view in terms of making it explicit that
the leech a management plan at the
outset needs to address um not just the
operating period but the post-closure
care period And I think what it really
does it just puts a current practice
into law and in our experience with
respect to doing compliance assurance
and enforcement having Provisions
directly in statute is is a powerful
thing you have to do it carefully
because we we can't have statutes that
are so lengthy and detailed that they're
going to be you know they're going to
look like administrative rules but for
certain things it's nice to have that
clear and explicit Authority in the
statute and with that I think I'd just
be happy to answer any questions thank
you representative
King thank you madam chair and thank you
for taking
questions
um philosophically um just aside from
this specific issue if there are
rules agency
rules um that are there do they have the
authority to wave those rules or not
enforce those rules because there seems
to be some questioning of why it is that
there' be rules that aren't being
enforced and I'm just wondering if they
have the authority to wave rules or or
and I'm not just saying specifically in
regards to to leate but just any rules
in general can they can can the agency
just choose to un enforce rules
the well the applicant um can make
application for if they feel that
there's a rule that they cannot comply
with but they have a they propose an
alternate way of addressing the concern
the the statute does allow the
department to entertain a request for a
waiver of a specific Rule and then in
the rules there are specific criteria
that need to be met in order for the
Department to approve that waiver
request so we do that sparingly but it
does happen uh in some cases okay follow
up follow up sure thank you for that um
now getting back to the specific Topic
at hand it um is it your contention that
there have been rules in place regarding
lee8 that have not been enforced and and
if so have there been any applications
for such no no we we I don't believe we
have any applications for waivers with
respect to leech 8 management and the
department um always Endeavors to
enforce all of its rules in including
the Lee rules and I I believe that we
are doing that thank you representative
guber thank you for uh coming here and
testifying once again um it was stated
earlier that this bill uh will constrain
the rulle making process and uh you
understand that in your agency very
closely do you think that's the case or
with the your discussions with the
representative gerana that this would
not be the case again I I have not
actually seen this physically seen the
amendment but I think I know what it
looks like based on the discussions
we've had um and and the and the
sponsor's description of it here this
morning I don't see any particular areas
where it constrains the department in a
way that would cause concern for us okay
thank you very much any other questions
represent Bixby um yeah so one of the
things that seems to be a little bit
unclear still uh just in terms of our
knowledge is what how the enforcement
process
works sure sure so um you know our
approach not just in the solid waste
program but across the es programs is to
use you know compliance assurance and
enforcement in order to ensure we have
compliance with rules and compliance
Assurance starts with education it
starts with educating the regulated
parties on what the requirements are
that they have to comply with and then
it's monitoring which means inspections
or or paperwork reviews whatever is more
appropriate to determine whether the
rules are being complied with and in
cases where we
identify
um non-compliance we uh do a tiered kind
of a tiered structured process where we
we request compliance could be through
an informal letter could be through a
letter of deficiency that's issued um
and if that's not uh effective then we
we have the authority under specifically
under our Solid Waste program to issue a
unilaterally a unilateral administrative
order to compel compliance and that is
basically an enforceable document that
that uh that require that lays out what
the violations are and and gives the
applicant or gives the uh the regulated
party a certain amount of time to come
into compliance and demonstrate
compliance and then if that doesn't
happen again in the case of the solid
waste program we have both um uh
Authority through the using the New
Hampshire Department of Justice to seek
uh injunctive relief through civil or
criminal enforcement and also to issue
um civil penalties so that's the kind of
the gamut of what could
happen Okay representative
ktoa thank you madam chair and thank you
director for being here and taking my
question we've been hearing a lot about
lee8 um which we know needs to be
managed
um I just had a question because in 2023
we had a catastrophic event in New
Hampshire um with flash flooding um in
certain areas where landfills were now
under a
Lee does a
Lee 8 management plan plan for those
catastrophes or and when or when they do
happen what does the how does the
department handle that and are do you
have Personnel to help guide
[Music]
um and help with mitigation I guess in
those events um because as as you know
2023 was a catastrophic year so sure Lee
management plan is really intended to be
comprehensively look at what can happen
over the life of the landfill and we
know it's it's no you know it's clear to
us that there are going to be extreme
precipitation events both in terms of
duration and intensity that are going to
stress those systems and so those
systems are uh required to be designed
to handle certain um level of uh
precipitation event and in the case
where the more extreme events happen
there are Provisions made to store up to
12 in of leech heate on the liner and in
fact we have had you know a facility
that has had violation significant
violations of that which we've referred
to the Hampshire Department of Justice
um for for enforcement uh but with
respect to what we do in practice you
know we we know that those those events
do stress these systems and there are
the lee8 management plan and the and the
the contracts and such that that uh
operate are required to have should make
provision for handling that and and
being able to realize there's going to
be an increased bulk of leech a that's
going to have to be managed for a period
of time and and then also to manage the
operations at the landfill to
effectively minimize the generation of
leech a because there are things you can
do to ensure that the bulk of the
precipitation that falls on a facility
um is collected and goes to storm water
collection before it ever contacts any
waste um so anything can do that that's
managed to storm water on the facility
and doesn't have to be collected and
trucked off but anything that contacts
the waste should be collected in the
lee8 management system and properly
handled as
lee8 thank you representative Penza and
then representative
Howard thank you madam chair and thank
you for my question I just want to
understand enforcement there's been um
hundreds of violation letters that have
been sent out so each one of those at
this point should have um penalties
could you tell me what the what the
amount of um monetary penalties have
been so far for all of these violation
letters in total the well to be clear I
don't believe there's been hundreds of
letters there were hundreds of examples
of individual days where there were
violations that occurred and we have a
number of enforcement documents that we
issued for that facility that address
those that name those and identify them
and compel compliance the whole issue of
um uh enforcement through any penalty
action has been referred to the New
Hampshire Department of Justice and I'm
unfortunately just not at Liberty to
discuss that until it's reconciled it's
still in
process okay representative
Howard thank you madam chair um before
with absent this law this act what does
the would the application for a permit
address adequately address leech
management I I someone earlier referred
to a gap is is that the Gap is the
detail sure an an application for a
permit today under today's statutory
language and under our today's
administrative rules absolutely does
require that um before we give operating
approval for a facility a detailed lee8
management plan needs to be included in
the operating plan for that facility and
that is subject to review and needs to
meet certain requirements it's reviewed
by Dees engineers and before that would
operating approval would be granted for
the facility we would look to that plan
to make sure that the operating plan
covers many things but with respect
specifically to leech a management that
it that it um describes an adequate and
and compliant program for collecting
managing and disposing of leech
eight representative minor thank you
madam chairman let's just Suppose there
is a catastrophic failure are the plans
in place to deal with this once it gets
into the once it gets into the aquifer
so to so to speak the camels got their
nose underneath the tent M right so if
in the case of uh we have a robust
system of monitoring for landfills that
requires that um monitoring Wells be
placed around the perimeter of the
landfill to monitor groundwater quality
to detect whether the landfill is have
any adverse impacts on groundwater
quality around the facility in the cases
where um detections of contaminant
are are made then um enhanced monitoring
happens and investigations are required
to identify the source of that whether
it's from a an errant problem with storm
water or whether it's an actual leech a
release or whatever it might be and then
if that's uh determined to be um at
issue then a corrective action plan is
required to address that U which could
which certainly includes stopping doing
whatever is necessary to to cease any
release that's occurring but also can
include a requirement to um treat any
contaminated groundwater to to restore
it to meet groundwater quality standards
followup followup thank you so once
again just let me be clear once once
there is a catastrophe let's say in the
what and and you say there's some
mitigation plans in place but suppose it
goes beyond that suppose it you know it
gets out of control was mentioned
earlier uh there was 10 and something
inches of leech eight in these liners
they not designed for that right we
we've made it clear that that's
non-compliant condition and and we're
seeking enforcement with respect than
you for that okay any other questions
from the committee representative Bigby
yeah so um this is uh in some sense a
follow up on representative Howard
Howard's question do you see this bill
uh with a potential Amendment you heard
this morning as providing the department
with or potentially providing the
department
with uh tools to create better uh
leachate management plans going forward
I would say anytime um a particular
Authority is INS sconed in the statute
directly and explicitly that's can be
helpful to us yes thank you thank you
any other questions represent
Penza thank you madam chair thank you
for taking my question um based upon the
information that I have researched um
over the the past 20 years of the for
example the Bethlehem facility has only
been charged $2,000 in civil penalties
um so do you are you saying that you
don't have the authority to impose fines
and if you're saying that do you just
send it over to the doj and wait and do
you know how many right now um are in
like holding pattern because $2,000 over
20 years doesn't seem like very
much um
we absolutely have authority to seek
penalties we we if to the extent that we
are seeking civil penalties or criminal
sanctions then we are required to work
with the Department of Justice to
accomplish that they're the they're the
arm of state government that has the
authority to to address those things in
the courts but we work closely with them
it's not as though we WR we refer it and
then just wait to see what they do our
staff our compliance staff and our
Engineers work with them to make sure
they understand the severity of the
violations and the concern and and you
know any penalties that are being
recommended uh as far as uh past history
um maybe it's more than 20 years I
believe there was another penalty that
was much more substantial than that that
was levied against that facility but it
it may be more than 20 years ago that it
occurred it was on the order of around I
believe around
$200,000 representative Scully thank you
madam shair and thank you for being here
um do the lee8 management plans that the
department reviews do they specify what
they anticipate to be the volume of lee8
and does your department require that an
excess volume of storage and treatment
be there to deal with some of these um
un you know planable events yeah I
generally those those plans would
include estimates of the amount of leech
a that would be generated and the
expectation is that the and the
requirement is that the applicant have
uh contracts and and
Outlet facilities that are capable of
managing both the routine uh everyday
amounts of leech a as well as uh area
you know times of increased um
generation of leech he8 there are
certain times when increased leech a is
going to happen because of the stage of
construction that a particular cell is
at so that when you have more of a cell
open to the precipitation you're going
to have increased volumes of lee8 and
the expectation is the applicant always
has
contractual um uh agreements with
Wastewater facilities that can accept
those those
volumes okay uh quick followup so we do
not at this point specify any excess
capacity over and above what what
they're claiming to be the amount that's
being
generated I I'm not aware that there's a
rule that talks about excess Capac I
mean the again in practice what our
Engineers are doing is they're looking
at a Lee a management AG plan making an
assessment about whether it provides an
adequate um that that it's estimating
reasonable reasonably what could be
generated at the facility and then
making sure there's a plan for managing
that safely I I haven't personally
reviewed these so I don't I don't really
want to comment too too authoritatively
on that thank you okay representative
Bixby yeah so I'm like to get a little
bit back to the enforcement process and
uh so uh we have um articles about newsp
newspaper articles about um what seemed
to be an excessive number of violations
in
2024 uh at a particular landfill and you
have mentioned that uh you have re re uh
referred some of that issue to the
Department of Justice and I'm just
wondering uh are do you have limitations
about what you can say publicly when you
refer something to the Department of
Justice and what's the typical time
scale that it takes them to Res to come
out with a recommendation or a penalty
thank you for the question yeah it's
certainly the case that I'm not at
Liberty to discuss that case in any
detail at this point it wouldn't be
appropriate to do so while it's still in
process um the time period for these
sorts of things can be variable some
cases can be um sought and you know
initiated and settled fairly quickly or
or go to court um relatively quickly and
others may take more time it's it's
really I I don't think I think there's
an average we don't have a lot of these
cases and the reality is is that you
know from my perspective I mean I've
been spent much of my career allied with
uh compliance and enforcement programs
and um guys like me never think it's
fast enough that's just uh the way we're
wired but um uh I wish I could give you
an average but I don't think there
really is
one
followup so
um so so you said that you you can't
discuss that that case which I I'm not
I'm not asking you to discuss it but um
just in terms of the implications of
discussing it uh would discussing it um
create problems for the Department of
Justice to actually uh get the
information they need and create the
case without jeopardizing the the
ability to prosecute
it I'm sorry I'm not sure I understand
your question okay so there are certain
things you need to keep confidential
and uh is the reason that you need to
keep those confidential in order to
protect the ability of the doj to
actually prosecute the case right the I
think the general rule of thumb is and
it's a good one is that if you're in
engaged in enforcement that could end up
in litigation you should say nothing
about the case and outside of the the
actual activities of the case because it
just it you know if I say something
errant here or lless I'm going to end up
being deposed about it for8 hours when
if we go into litigation so there's no
advantage to that did it disadvantages
the state's case whenever a state
employee who's involved in enforcement
discusses publicly the the details of
that case and followup followup so uh
and in terms of time scale uh I know
that you is highly variable but um it
would be would you say it would be
really surprising to refer something to
the doj and get an get get something
back in say a month or
two uh for a if if if we referring for
civil penalties yeah that would be very
that would be very fast i' would be
surprised to see if that happen thank
you okay any other questions from the
committee representative Penza sorry
representative Bixby just brought up
some other things thank you madam chair
last question on this okay so I I think
he's talking about one thing I guess my
questions were down a different path so
if especially you know you have a you
have hundreds of violations that the
landfill knows that they're in violation
of these are penalties there there comes
with a a case of that that's all public
knowledge I'm not talking about further
investigations lawsuits or any of that
kind of stuff I'm talking about cut and
dry where we know certain things that
are coming directly from the landfill or
coming directly from you coming from
wastewater treatment plants that are all
clear-cut violations which has fines why
can't we know the number of those that
have been that have been sent or that
are um that are up in the air at this
point um that shouldn't be a secret
that's public information um so that's
my first question is why wouldn't why
can't we get that information and there
wouldn't be this need for this
investigation or any of that if these
are clear-cut cases which a lot of them
are any documents that been issued to
the to the permite um or any documents
at all other than our Direct
Communications with the Department of
Justice relative to this enforcement
case are absolutely public and you're
those are all available to this
committee or any member of the public
follow up follow up so could um I'm
asking for the agency to send the
committee just so we have that a list of
every single violation that has taken
place uh in the last two years for um
that landfill the Bethlehem landfill
please every single violation um I'd
love a a nice grouping of all of them
and if um if there is automatically in
statute or in place certain um number
amounts of what those violations would
cost that would be helpful to have that
as
well any other questions from the
committee seeing none thank you so much
uh director whimet from for uh coming to
speak with us about this bill this
morning and uh I would like the blue
sheet if anybody else has anything to
say I don't have any more pink
cards um I do know
that as was referenced
before uh regarding online testimony we
had 265 people write Us in support of
this bill and four
persons uh indicated that they oppose it
and the blue sheet is coming to us
shortly
okay thank
you on our blue sheet we had six person
sign in um in um support of this
legislation and with that I'm going to
close the hearing on HB
355 and our committee is going to
continue uh a full committee work
session we were supposed to start at 11:
so we we have less time though uh to
discuss um several bills that we've
already
heard so I'd like to start off um with
hb1 53 require requiring that two or
more law enforcement officers in this
County receive training regarding animal
cruelty um representative ktoa you have
some information for us thank you madam
chair I do have an amendment here that's
been drafted by OS that I'd like to hand
out to the committee um quickly okay
sure
may I speak to this while we're passing
it out absolutely may speak to this so
technically um this bill adds a couple
of the rsas that were excluded regarding
the
training but I think the important Point
here is under each section be of what we
heard uh the this line that says who is
able to respond to and or assist upon
request of local law enforcement
agencies
um
so I think that was really a point that
people were worried
about so it would be upon the request of
local foreign uh I think the word of
should be in there that's missing but if
you look at line
18 and
line N9 and
10 uh you'll see that
change okay represent Howard
um thank you madam chair um
representative K do you think that this
addresses that state policeman's
concerns about them ending up holding
the bag on these
cases I I I do because it's it's upon
the request of local law enforcement so
you know I've sat in and listened to a
lot of people that are concerned because
you know the aoc's in the area are
concerned that um our Animal control
officer the acos excuse me um should uh
might be overlooked or you know they
don't want their toes stepped on um this
would avoid make sure that that doesn't
happen um I know however based
on um the sheriff that testified is from
my County uh we actually get along very
well uh just for everyone's uh benefit
um but I actually had reason to call the
sheriff's department on an animal abuse
case that a constituent kept calling and
calling about
um during the heat wave that we had one
year regarding the horses that I
mentioned and local law enforcement had
no idea what they were doing there was
no ACO officer I called the sheriff's
department he's like I can't step in I
called the state vets office it's like
we don't have we can't do this and so at
one point the veterinarian did come out
but then for the state vet and
everything else to happen it was another
days so there there's a disconnect and
when we listen to the sheriff
you know when we told him that they
actually had to be accompanied
by they didn't know the
law and I think one two people in each
County in law enforcement that
understands a law that's on the state
books I don't think that's a lot to
ask follow up yep um yeah sorry it was
the sheriff not the state police officer
and so so this would not
in this would take away the the
possibility that the jurisdiction would
fall would tumble down to the to the
Sheriff's Office it would stay in it
would stay in the local
control it it could but it could not be
I mean we know that there are a lot of
communities in New Hampshire that are
small that don't have Animal Control
Officers and don't even really have a
full-time you know their Police
Department is so small they can't handle
these things we need some and the thing
is an animal control officer cannot do
enforcement they're not the law unless
they are deputized they don't have that
enforcement mechanism so you need
someone with the enforcement mechanism
to be able to go
in well I don't I think I think it was
pretty clear at least from testimony and
also
from from what I've heard uh in other um
instances where animal cruelty neglect
has been reported it's clear that law
enforcement needs to know
more about how to
enforce this or at least needs to know
more about what the statutes say because
uh it was clear to me that they don't
represent Bixby yeah so um what I think
that um there
are there there are a couple of issues
here one is um
uh do does law enforcement need more
education I think the the answer to that
is absolutely yeah and the question is
so the next question is what's the best
mechanism for getting that to them and
um I was uh I was particularly struck by
the testimony from the um from uh Mr I
think it was sipa orp uh the uh sipa
from the uh law enforcement Training
Academy who uh spoke to the fact that um
it might that the way that that there
there exists a structure of task force
task forces for uh doing different
aspects of law enforcement that um that
stru that's an existing structure and uh
it it does enable law enforcement to get
the get people who know the topic to the
right place at the right time uh and uh
I think that one of the issues with the
bill that uh as as it stands is that it
creates a structure that is not uh it's
not a structure that they deal with
already and so I think that moving
towards that task force structure might
be a better approach I'm also concerned
about the fact that it's going to cost
money and there's no money in the bill
uh and um so I I think what we probably
ought to do is send this to uh
subcommittee for uh more detailed work
and get you know and get um members like
Mr sippa and some other members of law
enforcement to come in and help us craft
something that works more around the
task force approach sure representative
kto thank you madam chair and uh thank
you representative Bixby um I think uh
that that would be a great idea for this
bill um I do think it does need some
more study uh and uh I think we could
get something really uh well written if
we do that great and I just like to make
a quick note that
um I initially thought well maybe this
is something we should retain but then I
looked I considered the deadline the
deadline is March 6 uh so it would have
to be out of committee a week before
that I think that should give us enough
time if we uh if we work on on it and um
given that all of our operations are
moving to Granite Place starting in the
fall is going to make it a lot more of a
nuisance to do um to do uh retained
bills this term so if we can get this
out before the deadline I think that
would be
great okay so I guess the uh
recommendation would be for us to put
this bill into the animal protection and
Licensing subcommittee
uh I did send around a
um uh a list of our subcommittees and
who is appointed to each of the
subcommittees and representative Kwa you
happen to chair that
subcommittee so if you'd like to uh take
this bill and work further on it uh with
the um with the thought of incorporating
a task force uh I would be very pleased
to see that happen thank you madam chair
it'd be my pleasure
okay
terrific all right um we have also a
bill that we had heard HB 215 requiring
a landfill permit applicant to submit a
report listing potential harms and
benefits of the project does anybody
have a comment on that and I see
representative ger
thank you madam chair uh when we held
the hearing on this uh on this bill uh I
took a number of notes based on comments
that uh members of the committee made
and I've identified three areas uh again
based on members comments where I think
there uh are opportunities to amend the
bill uh certainly things for us to talk
about what direction the bill might take
uh one certainly is a question about who
chooses the independent third party
uh we had Amy manzelli here who I think
gave us a a good description of kind of
how the process works that it's it's an
ongoing dialogue about the the third
party uh who is equipped to do that work
um but the bill should probably be
amended to be more specific about that
process it was one thing I heard another
question that came up uh which I think
as a committee we need to discuss is
whether or not it should apply to
expansions of um existing
landfills uh and then finally uh a
suggestion that was made by director
whims that I think is worthy of looking
into more is whether or not we might
have an initial screening process that
would have the net benefit component uh
as the first part of an analysis before
it then goes on to consideration for
other aspects of the permitting process
so those were based on members comments
the three areas that I thought
um were good for discussion of possible
Amendment who chooses a third party does
it apply to expansions and should we
have a two-stage screening uh process
representative Bixby yeah so um I think
that uh I think that uh two out of those
three of those definitely need more
should should include more work I think
that the who Cho who chooses a third
party is really critical and I think
that that needs to be clarified from
what St in the current bill and I think
that the initial screening process makes
a lot of sense I think that would be
good both for industry and for uh you
know all of the uh stakeholders because
uh if you if if something needs to go
back to the drawing board you want to
learn that earlier rather than later uh
uh in terms of does it apply to
expansions I think that with existing
landfills there is a fairly reasonable
argument to be made made that um the the
harms and benefits of an existing
landfill are already pretty well known
and uh I I think uh attorney maneli
talked about uh you know every every
project has harms and benefits and then
but it's the ones that are really out of
bounds that you need you most need to
watch out for I think that with existing
landfills You Don't See You Don't See
ones that the ones are already out of
bounds you know about already and that's
that has that has to get rectified in in
another way but
um but in terms of the general
operations what's the way it the this uh
the harms and benefits are pretty well
known for that so I don't think that
this it you definitely need you
necessarily need to create more
paperwork about
[Music]
those representative H Haskins thank you
madam chair um so rep Bixby are you
saying that expansions of existing
landfills don't need
this yes I'm I'm saying that expansions
don't need this because the point of
doing the harm benefit analysis is to
find out or to to do uh to make as
reasonable a prediction as possible
about what's going to happen on a site
that hasn't been developed yet if the
site is already developed the patterns
of traffic are known the patterns of uh
of noise complaints or odor complaints
are already known those fall into the
category of things that need to be
rectified if they are outside the permit
bounds as opposed to things that we need
to do an analysis of I recollect though
discussing the fact that a
1400 acre parcel that might be expanded
as one one section closes and another
opens might indeed have you know air
going a different direction might have
soil that's slightly different than the
one in the corner of the uh parcel
that's been uh closed down so I actually
think that expansion should be part of
the
bill representative
ger thank you uh Madam chair I
personally I think that I think the
argument can be made that a modified
version of this might apply to
expansions my sense is just as we're
talking here I probably would prefer in
this bill not to include expansions and
then we could return to the question of
whether a modified process might apply
to expansions I think that something
similar absolutely makes sense as
representative H Haskins points out but
as representative Bixby has pointed out
it is a different set of questions with
existing conditions as opposed to a site
that is brand new so um that's some one
of the things I would throw out there's
the possibility that for the time being
we exempt expansions uh and return in
the future to the possibility of a
modified process okay uh representative
guber uh thank you um I think the idea
of expansions should be looked at but I
I don't think we should tie down this
bill with another whole area uh on
expansions there are incremental impacts
and we should at least look at those
particularly if people have lived uh
near a landfill for many years and
they're hoping the truck traffic would
slow down when that it's filled so I
don't think we should discount the
people who live there into the future
you know um but I think it's a very
different type of situation that will
take really a study first and uh it
would definitely derail this bill if we
tried to solve it now so my proposal we
take a set track on that thank you
representative
Penza yeah um I agree with
representative guber on this uh on this
point um I think that if we're I think
we have to be specific in this bill and
we're talking about something that is
brand new and um and keeping that track
for permitting brand new um I do believe
that um that information there's a lot
of information that's readily available
um that could be comprised from an
existing landfill that's looking to
expand and uh I think that we could take
another bite of that at a different time
but for this bill and this bill alone I
think it's serving its purpose for that
and I
agree any other representative Bixby
yeah so it sounds like um we uh we have
a general idea of where should this
should be going going going forward and
I think that it probably needs to go to
the solid waste
subcommittee
okay representative
ktoa thank you madam chair um when doing
the when looking at this bill my
question is is one who's going to
determine net Ben public
benefit um we do have a definition of
public benefit but there is no
definition of net public benefit and so
I'm just asking that's just a question
which can be uh discussed in the
subcommittee representative
gerana uh thank you madam chair and and
I think represent comto for the question
it's an excellent question I agree it's
what the subcommittee can talk about and
and the director has indicated in his
comments that he can imagine some type
of initial screening phase that would
bring in experts so I think we have an
initial idea of what that might look
like and I think the subcommittee can
definitely work closer with the to
refine
that okay any other questions comments
about that bill okay so that
bill uh will'll be uh visiting the uh
solid was subcommittee uh representative
King you are chair of that
um and uh I guess you'll make
arrangements to meet as soon as you can
and discuss this and come up with an
amendment that incorporates what people
are seeking for for this bill um moving
along we have HB 240 which is removing
the penalty of forfeiture for
non-payment of dog
licenses anybody have any comments or
questions about that representative
Bixby yeah so I think that uh this is
one of those cases where there was a
real problem that uh was brought to us
and the solution was uh not the right
solution uh I think that uh the forer
statute really needs to stay in place
but I think that adding one sentence to
that statute that explicitly says that
uh the uh Municipal officials have the
capacity to provide a little bit of
leeway in order to uh improve compliance
uh would be in order and if uh if people
agree that that's not that's a
reasonable idea i' uh unless anyone else
wants to jump on and do that Amendment
I'd be willing to do that Amendment and
then bring it to the animal subcommittee
okay terrific uh representative Howard
um I agree with representative Bixby uh
that that very little is required and I
believe that the sponsor agreed with us
in the room that that it that was just
as simple as
that uh didn't he send didn't uh
representative um Manion send along a
suggested language did you did everybody
see that I did not see
that okay I I believe he sent something
to me I thought he sent it to the entire
committee I will forward that on to you
representative Bixby and um if you could
craft the amendment uh we can have that
for maybe next week speak y okay
super okay then uh we heard the bill
hb21 prohibiting the removal of Claws
from
cats
okay anybody have any comment on that
bill that we
heard representative ger thank you madam
chair I'll I'll only say that I know we
have this question uh this debate every
time
about you know statistics and and
whether or not we can ever really have
reliable statistics I I I think we can't
I think the fact that so many of the the
veterinarians that we hear from say it's
a disreputable practice um means that in
all likelihood some of the people who
are doing it are not going to be
reporting I think it's it's simply not
reasonable to say that that we can't go
forward unless we have
really accurate statistics because we'll
never have them in in my mind uh even
the the folks who testified in
opposition to the bill recognize that it
does happen some percentage of the time
and the number of cats that we have in
our shelters who have been declawed we
don't know how many of those are New
Hampshire how many are not but it's
unreasonable to assume if they're all
not New Hampshire cats to me that's
evidence that it's happening and and
from my perspective that is enough to
move forward with with uh support for
the bill okay I want to point the
committee out uh to a addendum that was
sent out by our committee researcher
Christy Al
aleser who um she she did we did she did
Supply a memo uh with some research
about the past bills and um that we
considered on Cat dclaw and noticed a
mistake in her
research uh regarding the second section
um she misread the survey question in
the 2020 data from the New Hampshire
Veterinary Medical
Association in actuality the question
read do you provide any similar services
such as tail docking ear cropping do
claw removal Etc that may be considered
illegal with passing of New Hampshire
Bill
1387 this question does not mention
declaw at all do claws are the rear
claws on a dog that can be removed
because they can get caught and ripped
off so um those 146
responses uh did not have anything to do
with um
declawing and uh so I just wanted to
point out this addendum to the committee
as you consider this personally I am I
am not in support of this bill I think
first of all it does undermine
Veterinary autonomy we haven't to this
point been telling veterinarians what
they can and cannot do what um in terms
of
procedures um I do think as in I'm
seeing you know so many bills across the
country uh similar bills coming to other
State
legislatures uh with this exact same um
prohibition I'm I'm seeing that it's a a
Gateway for restricting other procedures
for our
veterinarians I also believe very
strongly that by Banning it it limits
the
veterinarians ability to have
conversations with their clients about
decoying if you're Banning something
completely there's no opportunity for
somebody to come in and say I want to
declaw my cat and for the veterinarian
to then educate them about how bad it is
or what what's wrong with it or or even
what they can do for behavior
modification
uh for the animal to you know do other
things uh other than this very last
ditch effort to uh control a behavior um
but mostly it's not a common practice or
significant issue in New Hampshire that
I can see um and very very small
percentage of cats experience any kind
of Behavioral changes following deying
many many owners have contacted me and
let me know that you know they have a
declawed cat and they have had had no
problem using the litter box or biting
or doing any of these other things that
U people have have uh testified to so
you know I don't endorse decoying as a
first option I think you know it's just
like with landfilling it's like the last
thing you want to do decl is the last
thing that you want to do and we have to
have um an area a space where our
veterinarians can have a conver ation
with their clients about why they
shouldn't and I see um the market is
moving more towards you know it has
moved significantly from the even the
1990s away from this procedure naturally
because people don't like it um so for
all those reasons and more um I just I
can't support this
bill representative Freeman thank you
madam chairman thank you for so
eloquently spelling that out because I I
share that sentiment along with the fact
that I had a lot of um um Pro this bill
groups call me about it and I was I was
on the fence um there was compelling
testimony on either side of the issue
but the thing that narrowed it down for
me is numbers I'm a numbers person I
need to see numbers and we don't have
any way to know how many of these
procedures are occurring in the state
how many procedures have the Vets talked
to with their clients about this and
really what is the overall practice and
there really was no tangible evidence
that putting a ban in place would
mitigate any of those things so again I
want to thank you for so eloquently
pointing out why um I as well don't feel
this bill should go forward thank you uh
representative H Haskins thank you madam
chair with respect I do support the bill
um I don't believe it's taking agency
away from the Vets I think cat owners
will still bring their cats into the
that and they can have whatever
conversation they need to have um while
I wish there were hard numbers I think
we do know that it's happening there's
enough anecdotal evidence to support
that and I don't think that law should
be a statement of who we are but I think
this
time who we are is that we think it is a
cruel practice so I believe it it should
be outlawed and and i would support that
representative Miner thank you madam
chairman I don't I I don't I can't
support this bill I don't see it that
that it's our responsibility nor our
duty to tell uh veterinarians um what
they can and cannot do in their practice
um It's a Long Reach for us and um I
just can't support it if we if we
support this what's next
I I uh no I can't support this thank you
representative Bixby so I I think that
uh we are at a we are at a position
where uh it is clear that some people on
this committee feel that the bill should
pass others feel it should not and I
don't think that any more discussion at
this point is going to change that those
positions uh but the so the key question
is is there anything that can that would
need to be done to amend this bill for
any purpose and my sense is no the bill
either passes or fails as it is and we
should just put it on exec and each
person will make their own decision
based on uh the uh the the the ways they
choose to evaluate the Bill thank you
representative
ktoa uh well I I was going to say now
that uh represent Bixby decided uh he
made a good point and I was just going
to bring up the fact that you know in
speaking with different veterinarians
and folks um my veterinarian in
particular has did one declaw in 5 years
um his when people would bring PE um
when the owners would bring in the
patients he would discuss the procedures
and um
uh obviously only one in five years uh
they all opted not to uh the one that he
did do it was that or euthanized the
cat um so
and the owner was very passionate about
her uh
animal um and I think we have to respect
that um and just knowing my vet and you
know
he
uh he
understands and I don't know and I
haven't talked to any and we've talked
to the abma and we've talked to
different vets
that the first course of action for
anyone bringing in a cat for decla is
educating them and once most people are
educated they ought not
to but this is a doctor patient uh
relationship and by Banning that you're
taking away that
relationship represent Penza you had
something you wanted to
say otherwise we can move
on yeah I just um in just in resp
response to representative Bixby I
actually think that the bill should be
amended I think that I could support the
bill if it was amended I would want the
penalties removed I would want uh on I
can't pronounce it I would want the U
the term defined I would want an ad I
would want I would want this bill to be
different I don't like how it's um I
don't like how it's um been designed and
and to me after it failed the first time
like it failed the first year why wasn't
a bill put in why wasn't it amended to
get the data that we're looking for to
get the data from every single shelter
in the state of New Hampshire to find
out where the numbers are to get the
data from from vets that are performing
it so I mean I just I think that there
should be things that are in here that
change for example I um the general
court affirms our trust in the expertise
compassion and ethical Judgment of
licensed New Hampshire veterinarians to
make decisions in the best interest of
animals under their care I think those
things need to be said in here because
we have heard both sides of the story
here and I don't know what's true I do I
know I did my due diligence last time I
don't like how the bill is organized
because I think it it it opens the door
for this tattletail type mentality and
uh I think that's a slippery slope
besides other things like that um I want
the data I I would love this to I would
love this to be in statute to say we
don't do them except if it's medically
necessary for the cat and then there
could be a caveat there of course
medically necessary for the owner and
I'd be fine with it and remove the
penalties but it doesn't seem as if we
just keep doing the same thing over and
over and expecting different results so
I will not I can't support it how it
currently is if someone's willing to do
an amendment um to get this to a place
where I think we could all and to
include both parties the the Vets as
well as everyone that is against this
this is a barbaric procedure everybody
knows that if I read anything else about
it I'm going lose my mind I've had a
gazillion calls from this from my local
constituents and uh I want to be able to
support something but not in its current
version thank you representative H
Haskins and then representative Kenny
then I guess we'll have to go to lunch
sure one last comment I don't want to
hold up lunch I was schooled by an
deemed colleague that the slippery slope
argument is a fallacy as taught in
rhetoric that's
all thank you representative
Kenny uh yes um I worked at a veterinary
hospital for 21 years we did declaw by
taking just the nail
off and the incision was closed with
glue and the um Veterinary would close
it off with glue we would have the
client put the cats on shredded
newspaper for 2 weeks and those cats did
fine this was 21 years and we had no
trouble this whole thing about taking
off an entire knuckle was the old way of
doing things not the new way I have
people the clients that were what we had
had cats for many many years after we
declawed them that way we did not do the
back claws so they could still climb a
tree if they needed to this whole thing
about taking the whole entire knuckle
off is
wrong I watched it for years close the
incision up with glue let them heal with
newspaper and there was no trouble I
don't know this whole thing is just if
it if an veterinarian we shouldn't be
questioning what they do with
surgeries it's not right representative
Bixby so um we have one more bill that
needs to that we need to address before
and that it would be good to dress
before we go to lunch and uh and I think
that there are two possible ways of
going about the uh the declaw Bill one
is to look into the possibility of
amendment I think that it might make
sense to have a straw poll to see how
many people would be interested in
amending it but before we do that I just
like to recommend that we send the bill
that we heard this morning to uh the
solid way study committee uh uh for
Amendment because uh the prime sponsor
does have an amendment that he wants to
work on with
that okay um fine with that anybody else
have a issue with that okay so we would
be then sending HB 566 to the solid
waste subcommittee to uh refine an
amendment to that all right I'm good
with that um and as so far as the
um uh the cat claw bill um I I I think I
don't know that I want to waste the time
uh doing um a whole rework of the bill
it's not our job really to rewrite
somebody else's bill
um
perhaps you know I'm sure that if we
don't if this bill doesn't pass I'm sure
we're going to see it back again so
maybe at that point we could have H A
bill that uh maybe makes a little bit
more sense in one way shape or form but
um I think we should move
on with that I'm going to adjourn us for
lunch and see you back at 1:00 when we
will begin hearings on on a couple of
more
bills uh today let's see which ones
that's
uh HB 355 which should take all of 15
minutes to hear um HB 179 HB 171 and hr3
so we will see you all later at 1
o'clock and I hope you all have a
pleasant
lunch
e
e e
okay good afternoon members take your
seats
please members take your seats
please oops
oh that's why okay okay uh welcome back
to environment and agriculture committee
I appreciate everybody uh coming this
afternoon the first B bill that we are
going to hear going to open up the
hearing on HB
355 relative to the membership of the
solid waste working group and I invite
representative eel to come and introduce
the bill good
afternoon good afternoon Madam
chairwoman and uh committee it's great
to be back in uh environment and
agriculture um my for the record my name
is Karen eel I represent marac district
7 which is New London and Newbury and
I'm here to introduce HB
355 which would extend the term of the
solid waste working group for 5 years
and replace the position of the
Northeast Recycling Council also known
as nerk um with the society for the
protection of New Hampshire forests um
the the working group was established by
Statute in 2021 and pursuant to the
terms of the statute it's required to
issue its final report and terminate on
November 1st um I'm also here in my
capacity as the chairman of the solid
waste working group and um it is with
the group's support that I introduced
this bill just uh quickly I can run down
the background of the of the working
group back in
2019 I also chaired a legislative study
committee um that issued a report and it
was to study recycling streams and solid
waste in New Hampshire and one of the
recommendations coming out of that study
committee um was that there be created
here in the state a stakeholder group
representing uh the solid waste uh issue
from folks all over the place and um it
was also thought that this would be a
good kind of um connection for Dees
because uh one of the requirements once
the group was uh created was to work
with de s on a um Solid Waste Management
plan it was a long range plan and uh if
you've been on this committee you
probably know it was about 20 years late
in being issued but the great news is
that it has been issued um and we did
work with Dees on its development the
other thing that we are responsible for
is to um review all sorts of alternative
to approve improve the solid waste
management here in the state of New
Hampshire and um also to support the
solid waste management plan goals and
one of those goals as many of you also
know is that we have a newly adopt Solid
Waste
diversion uh goal statute and we're
supposed to um decrease the tonage going
into landfills and waste energy plants
of solid waste uh 25% by 2030 which
isn't that far away and then 45% by 2050
so those are all the sorts of things
that we're um that we're working on um
it's a very I know there's a lot of
concern about creating new commissions
or extending commissions that are more
abund if there's anything this
commission isn't it's more abund we work
on it's not morand it um we work a lot
we meet regularly even though we're not
required to we've been issuing um annual
interim reports to talk about the work
that we've been doing
um and also because you're on Ena you
probably know that we have supported
several bills through the working group
um one was to uh ban the disposal of one
ton uh generators of more or more food
waste B that disposal in landfills and
requiring it to be composted and that is
about to become effective February 1 so
maybe you've seen the media on that and
that will um help us towards our
diversion goal we also successfully
supported um a bill to create and fund
uh the solid Waste Management fund and
that is a grant program for Waste
diversion for municipalities and
businesses we've got um a million
dollars in that and that's about to kick
off last time uh the we supported a bill
to ban the sale of consumer products
with intentionally added pasas Banning
the disposal of lithium ion batteries
which are a huge risk in landfills um
and to authorize the inclusion of waste
diversion plans in town Master plans so
we've been we've supported legislation
that is
Meaningful uh supports our Solid Waste
Management plan goals and also has been
supported by the legislature and the
governors so um I'm I'm proud of the
work that that we've done and we'd
really like to be able to continue the
work and that's why this bill would
extend the term of the solid waste
working group for five years so the
lastly uh what is proposed in this
legislation is to replace nerk uh which
is a terrific organization but it's a
regional organization it's not based in
New Hampshire and ever since the
creation of um of the working group I
think nerk in the very beginning a
representative have attended twice
remotely and they really haven't
attended any meetings and the and the
nerk executive director doesn't really
feel that they'll be able to um
participate much in the future and she
supports being removed from the
commission um and then in an effort to
make uh the working group uh more State
focused to improve its analysis and its
stakeholder representation
HB 355 proposes to uh replace nerk with
a representative of the society for
protection of New Hampshire forest and
they obviously are concerned about water
and land and Air in the state of New
Hampshire and it's a voice I think has
been missing on the stakeholder group
and we'd love to have them join us and I
believe there's a representative of the
society here but um having spoken with
him um I believe they are interested in
joining the commission so on that basis
I urge the committee um on behalf of the
working group to recommend passage of
this bill extending uh the term for
another five years and replacing nerk uh
with um someone from the society and I'd
be happy to take your questions thank
you representative evil and I just want
to say as a member of the solid waste
working group
excuse me being appointed by the house
as the house representative on that
group it's done some very good work
especially under your chairmanship and I
appreciate the time uh taken by all
interested parties and stakeholders uh
to discuss and pursue and investigate
and explore all the different aspects of
our solid waste policy in the state so
um I am in full support of this bill and
uh I'll leave it to question questions
from representative
wheeler thank you madam chair thank you
representative eel for taking my
question I don't have a questioned about
the group itself seems like you guys are
doing fantastic work and working
regularly to meet the demands of a
commission when we don't want so many
commissions that aren't meeting
regularly my question is about the word
abund now what does that word mean is
more abund yeah more abund well uh tired
and not not Opera
I could okay thank um I I just want to
say on and this was something I I had
meant to say when I was originally
testifying I for uh about a year and a
half chaired two different uh committees
that were responsible for reviewing
every single uh statutory commission and
uh Committee in existence at the state
at that time and it was almost 250 of
them and um we worked
diligently uh and also there we were
talking about executive orders that had
created such things and we worked very
diligently to recommend repeals uh of
ones that deserve to be repealed and
were more abund um and also to try to
put more um oomph into the statutes that
allowed their their creation I also
served last year on the special
committee on commissions so I'm pretty
particularly sensitive to ensuring that
if we're going to have a commission it
should be active if it's going to be
ongoing okay thank you represent
representative guber uh thank you madam
chair uh representative evil uh thank
you I've heard great things about this
group um could you help educate me about
what are the other stakeholder groups
that are represented on this group
because I'm still trying to yeah of
course um so in my testimony when you
have a chance there's a link to our most
recent interm report and right in there
is listed all the members but we have
um representatives of municipalities
that have uh that sort their recycling
rep a municipality that has single
stream we have somebody from the health
care industry we have somebody from UNH
to represent the uh
sustainability concept we have someone
from I never say it right Northeast
resource recovery Association nrra
Reagan Binet is on there we have a
representative of um for uh landfills uh
privately owned some another
representative for publicly owned trans
uh landfill somebody that represents uh
they reprocess CND d uh waste to
energy um I think that's about it oh and
somebody we we do have a representative
on there of someone that uses recyclable
goods to create post uh to to create new
consumer products using recycled plastic
in this case it's a Bottling Company
well thank you very much sure any other
questions from the
committee seeing none thank you very
much representative EO and thank you
again for all the great work that you're
you're doing with that committee
um I call Matt lehy Ley sorry
um from forest Society you have two
minutes good afternoon thank you madam
chair uh for the record I'm Matt Ley I'm
the public policy director for the
society for the protection of New
Hampshire Forest um I did pass out uh
written testimony I'm not going to read
it um I'll of course answer any
questions from it that you have but I
would just say make a couple hopefully
quick points number one and to be very
upfront you know we the for society we
are not experts in the area of solid
waste management um but we are a land
trust and Forestry organization so we
protect land conserve land either by
owning it ourselves or holding
conservation easements on other
privately held land uh we also manage
the forest resources on the on the
properties that we we do own um but you
know when we but I think the the value
that we would bring to this group is
that you know when we are considering
whether or not to protect a specific
property you know we look at the whole
you know what what are the important re
natural resources there whether it's
water Forest you know Forest
resources you know e uh recreational
interests cultural the so the whole
gamut that goes into a particular
property and so
um you know I think that perspective um
on the working group as representative
eil mentioned I I I think would bring
value you to the group um and certainly
the um study commission report from
2019 you know it does talk about you
know when we are when the state is
trying to figure out all these you know
Solid Waste issues you know it is a
long-term issue it's very common Lex so
hopefully that we can help you know
bring some additional um you know views
into the work of the committee thank you
but I'll happy answer any questions okay
any questions from the committee seeing
none thank you very much for your
testimony today um I now call director
Michael whimet from New Hampshire
Dees good afternoon Madam chair members
of the committee I'll be very brief uh
for the record my name is Mike whimet I
serve as director of the waste
management division for New Hampshire
Dees um the agency's not taking a
position on this bill I will offer
though that we've been working very
closely I am the commissioner's
designity to that working group so I've
been working with it since its Inception
it is uh it represents a very uh it's
its members represent diverse knowledge
and diverse um perspectives that really
have created I think a we we believe a
um very collaborative and productive
organization a working group that as you
know as outlined by representative eel
has had been very successful in
advancing a number of initiatives and we
would uh certainly look forward to
working with the group if it were if it
if it turns out that it's a mission will
be extended and I'll leave it at that
any questions from the
committee seeing none thank you very
much for your testimony um and uh I with
that I don't have any other pink cards
so I would request the blue sheet from
over there please representative Miner
if you might representative Miner if you
might uh grab the uh blue sheet for for
this it's uh HB
355 um for the online testimony we had
58 people in support two in
opposition and let's see what we have on
our blue sheet
here we have six people who have Reg
registered uh support for this bill on
our blue sheet and I'm going to close
the hearing on HB
355 and I wonder if the um um ranking
member would mind if we exect this bill
right
now I think it would make sense to exec
it right now I think that um it's pretty
clear that this is something that we
want to continue want to go forward and
we might as well make it go forward
expeditiously okay are we all all right
with that okay great so with that um I
would like to uh yeah you the clerk has
to get ready to Executive I have a
moment please you may have a moment um
in as you get ready to do
this do have have sheets for I do I
should
yeah to make a motion yes would you like
it to make a motion representative
Bixby are you ready I'm not quite ready
now okay will take me a minute I'm sorry
don't worry about
it that's a yeah I mean it's yes please
this HP
355 you're good to
go you just have to write in the motion
okay so uh we have to make the motion
yes representative Bixby you have a
motion yes I would like to move out to
pass on HB um 3 55 and I'd like to
second that
motion would you like to speak to your
motion representative Bixby um I think
that this bill makes a lot of sense the
solid waste working group has uh a great
track record for uh helping move forward
the uh our practices having to do with
solid waste in the state and I think
that uh it's clear that the change of
membership is wanted by both parties so
um let's just pass this
okay uh will the clerk then call the
role beginning with the vice
chair representative coma
yes representative
Kenny
Penza yes representative
Freeman uh clerk votes
yes Representatives
Scully
yes representative
Barber
yes representative Miner yes
representative Bixby
yes representative sopus absent
representative german
yes representative H Haskins
I representative Howard yes
representative wheeler
representative
Gruber okay and uh yes uh uh chairwoman
Aon
yes okay we have uh 19 Ys and one absent
motion passes one absent doesn't count
one absent doesn't count so it's 19 Z
okay oh my apologies 16 15 yeah
yes 15
nothing
okay um and would the uh would the
committee be okay with this being on the
consent
calendar there's yeah okay thank you all
right with that um I guess I Clos the
exec session which I guess I didn't
close now I open it and close it okay
anyway um moving right along um I will
open up the hearing for HB 179 relative
to hazardous waste accident fees and
with us is the sponsor of the bill um
representative Mark
Pou good afternoon thank you so
much good afternoon Madame chair and the
members of the committee my name is Mark
PR representing Hillsboro 15 which is
Manchester Ward
8 so today I come presenting House Bill
reference to uh the fees payment of the
fees
or for hazardous materials uh actions so
when we have an incident we're going to
use
equipment uh to mitigate that plus a lot
of our equipment gets contaminated or
destroyed so there there's a RSA that
says who's ever responsible for that
hazardous materials incident
has to
pay so we submit a invoice to them they
have 30 days to look at that invoice if
they don't think it's right they can
challenge it after the 30 days if they
haven't challenged
it they're responsible for
for the
bill um we get challenged
on you know
how old was your your turnout
gear and I'm not really sure how that
plays because you can't go buy used
turnout gear to replace my used turnout
gear you have to buy me new turnout gear
or hoses or the uh pads or whatever
other things that we use for the
mitigation of that incident has to be
replaced there's no use so um but
it used to
be a
$1,000 fine if they didn't pay the
bill well if the bill is
$50,000 that's a deal here's $1,000 I'm
all set so my amendment to that RSA is
that it should be $1,000 per day after
the 90 days they have up to 90 days to
come up and pay the bill after the 90
days it should be $1,000 a day plus the
20%
penalty uh until you
reach the price of the bill with the 20%
over that and those fines should be paid
to the
municipalities that have used that
equipment that who are not being paid
and this is a way to finally get paid if
these fees aren't
paid the has hazardous material teams
the fire departments have
trouble working they they're funding and
I have Chief deandreis with me uh who's
the uh president of uh the seos HazMat
team and he can giv you a more detailed
how that works and how it is so
important to get the money to replace
the equipment because there's very
little funding for HazMat teams in this
state so if we don't get to our
equipment we're not ready for the next
incident and with that I'll take
questions thank you um representative
ktoa then Howard thank you madam
chairman thank you for being here
presenting this bill you talked about um
you not being able to be reimbursed for
you
can so
I come the from the fire department not
a hatmat team so the latest incident
that I was involved in involved Oil
Trucks I got knocked to the ground and
got covered in oil along with my turnout
gear once it has oil on it we can't go
into burning buildings with it anymore
so it is contaminated it got taken from
me at the
scene
um so now our department has to replace
that and to replace a set of turnout
gear is between 7 and
$10,000 per
member we lost a bunch of
Hose we have to replace
that um the HazMat team that use uh
booms or absorbing pads to
mitigate the flow of the oil all has to
be
replaced uh there's very very little
funding to replace those you know they
over time they've made a stockpile and
if they use that stockpile then unless
we get paid for what we use it it's hard
to build that back up again okay
followup representative ktoa thank you
madam chair and thank you for that um do
you work in conjunction with Dees on
these um accidents
yes one more um thank you m chair uh so
does dees also access penalties and
fines and collect
monies I'm not
sure I would imagine there might be some
fines if if wrongdoing happened
representative Howard and then Miner
thank you madam chair hello
representative nice to see you again
nice to see you so I I is it when you
when the when you lose equipment and it
gets replaced the does it fine start
with the cost of the equipment or $1,000
because it sounded as if it's $1,000 a
day starting at day one or is it the
cost cost and then $1,000 after 90 days
or 60 days so so after 90 days so
originally the the fine was $1,000 after
90 days if they didn't
pay so they don't
pay ,000 or a th000 kind of a no-brainer
so that's why I put this in that if it
becomes $1,000 a
day up to 20% over what the bill is it
gives them incentive to just pay it
right so if we can get paid in a timely
fashion that would be great but if it's
just
$1,000 they're going to drag drag it out
or not pay it all and we'll end up in
court and you know how long that
takes okay representative Miner and then
um Penza and Freeman thank you
representative cre um I got a question
for you our town recently I'm going to
say recently within the past couple of
years what the large industrial uh
washing machine that is supposed to
clean and uh clean and wash out all the
Hazardous Materials on these turnout
gear can you speak to that so the
extractor doesn't get all the oil out it
gets a lot of the fire products out like
carbon and and those things but um very
rarely does it get all of the oil
residue that becomes embedded from what
I understand and uh and and I was told
um we couldn't get our gear back CU it's
just too contaminated to be cleaned
thank
you okay representative Penza and then
Freeman thank you madam chair um just to
kind of understand the process so for
example let's say it's XYZ company
there's a spill you know let's just use
your example all that equipment gets
destroyed so does the fire department
then uh send like the the bill the fines
or what ever directly to XYZ company so
we don't do fines but we will take an
inventory of what was damaged okay we
will look up replacement costs of that
equipment and present them with an
invoice within 30 days okay so the XYZ
company gets the invoice within 30 days
and you're saying that right now um
there's that's not they're not paying
correct because the the fine for not
paying is
$11,000 and so now this whole this and
that's still in place or does that that
right now is still in place until we get
this P correct correct thank you
representative Freeman and then Bixby
thank you madam chair thank you
representative for coming in front of us
today um I have a question about the way
you've structured this penalty I have a
Tac question is that all right sure sure
thank you so much um for allowing me
some latitude um would this also uh
apply to private residences
say if it was my house my house is
burning and you're exposed to something
hazardous in my house uh totally
different if it's in conjunction with a
fire that something gets released yes um
like at a private residence you had a
can of gasoline in the in the thing on
my oil tank or your oil
tank that is outside of this it doesn't
get included in this okay okay that that
as far the way I understand it okay
thank you and this is the thank you
madam chair I appreciate that um I do
have a question about the way the
penalty is structured so and and please
forgive me I want to understand this
100% it's to be paid to the claimant
which would be the municipality the city
the town correct at $1,000 per day plus
interest assessed at the rate of
interest established in RSA
3361 and an additional 20% of each day's
penalty for non-payment after 90 days of
the initial non-payment is that not
correct correct so what I was looking
for and I kind of left this to the
drafter and we all know how that goes
which is never a good idea yeah so
uh my thought
is the fine
starts at $1,000 a day after 90 days
instead of just the
$1,000 and be done so if they choose to
pay the whole bill after three days then
that gets absorbed and we're we're all
done okay
so I didn't know how to
better uh and maybe there's a better way
to get them to come and and and pay in a
timely fashion and that's what I'm
trying to get right because the HazMat
team is out out their equipment our our
department dug
into a pile of money that wasn't in our
budget so we could get our turnout gear
replaced because we wouldn't have it um
so they're waiting to get that money
back so they can put the money back
where they took it from uh so I'm
figuring if they're looking at $1,000 a
day
until they've reached their payment
with a 21 20% over that price however
you figure that out it should be some
penalty in there for making me wait for
$50,000 another 50 days to get paid for
our
equipment thank you representative Bixby
yes thank you madam chair I uh I also
have a I'm a little bit confused about
the um about the the way that the
payment mechanism is is is laid out
because the I'm open to suggestions I I
just want to clar I so I I just want a b
little bit of clarity about the goal um
so and I'm just going to read from look
at the bill I submitted rather than the
the other one um so in the bill is
submitted um then that thousand of
dollars a day can start starts at at 90
days and then goes until the bill
payment is received right
um followup followup and uh
so is that $1,000 a day going to be on
top of the cost of replacing equipment
no okay that's why I kind of put the
amendment in I'm trying to get the cost
of the replacement right so at a $1,000
fine wasn't doing it so if I get to fine
you up to the cost of the Equipment Plus
a 20%
penalty that's motivation to pay it okay
so so the goal is to uh have the fines
result in the reimbursement
reimbursement plus a 20% penalty for
which will um provide an incentive to
actually do it sooner correct okay uh I
I think we might need to do a little bit
of amendment but I think this is I I
think the concept makes a lot of sense
thank you okay representative Scully
thank you madam chair thank you for
being here and taking the questions um
what I don't see here is any
proportionality so if you send a bill
for $100,000 to one person and you send
$5,000 to another person you if that
person doesn't pay the $5,000 fine he's
going to be hit with $1,000 a day with
no
endpoint no there's an end point when
when you reach whatever the bill is it
stops I don't think I told the drafter
to put that in and maybe I need to get
it drafted again but once you
reach the amount of the bill the fine
stops and then 20% right so there's 20%
along with that so if it was
$100,000 120
right okay yeah I I just didn't see that
language in here right now so you're
intending to amend this to yep okay
thank
you representative
K thank you madam chair I was just
looking over the RSA and um one of the
representatives brought up about uh a
fire at their home and the part that
struck me and and maybe you can help me
here it says
here the response to fires or other
emergencies where the discharge of haard
materials is incidental to the fire
or other emergency and does not require
the use of
specialized ha materials shall not be
cost eligible but if there is use they
would still be eligible to for the cost
AC the way I'm I'm just asking because
further up it talks about whether by
knowledgeable or even a mission that you
didn't know um your responsib for this
so uh I'm just a little concerned that
somebody may have something hazardous
where you have to call in
Hazmat that the homeowner or somebody
that has no idea that they would need a
Hazmat person in there and how that
would affect them I'm going to tell you
from experience that if it's such a
small item that the person who has it
doesn't know that they're going to need
a haard mat team they probably
won't right but if you have a a a 5,000
gallon tank of oil sitting in your
backyard and it you haven't maintained
it and it let's go then you're going to
be responsible for it or your insurance
company you're okay representative Penza
did you have a question yes sorry thank
you madam chair
do you think it makes sense to
um just because there is a little bit of
ambiguity from what representative ktoa
just said in that that we should um
maybe further explain that in your bill
I just of course if someone has
hazardous materials on their property
that are not allowed by law that it
makes sense that they would be
responsible for that I get that but it
just I don't know I I don't want to open
us open it up for um you know a a
private you know private Citizen
Homeowner something like that um to get
hurt with this when you know is there do
you think that there's a pathway that we
could as you look at the
RSA we would build them anyway so right
if if they fell into the realm and I
know the person behind me has better
answers than I do
uh fell into the realm of that it was a
Hazmat
incident they're going to get an
invoice for the equipment no matter what
right and they were going to get find
$1,000 right if if their insurance
company didn't pay and that's who
becomes responsible is the insurance
company insurance company
okay okay thank you
I have a question for you um was there a
particular incident or something that
happened which triggered this uh this
legislation to be submitted by you and
unfortunately I can't talk about that
I'm sorry and unfortunately I can't talk
about that because it's being litigated
as we speak ah okay thank you for that
huh unfortunately
yeah all right uh any other questions
from the
committee okay seeing n thank you very
much for uh introducing this bill and I
call now uh Donald
d'angelus from SE Coast HazMat
team it's on no you just turned it on
there you
go I am the the chair please state your
name and where you from thank you I'm
Don d'angeles I'm the eping fire
chief and I am the chair of the Hazmat
team on the Sea Coast region and there's
eight teams in the state all of them are
locally funded we and we survive off
grants and local funding so each town
that is a member of the team uh they
contribute their portion generally our
budgets 151,000 a year most of that's
consumed by training and uh anything
else that we use for equipment stuff as
Mark said if there's a spill uh the
insurance companies generally uh repair
replace uh all of the damaged and
degradated equipment so we rely heavily
on billing uh you asked Mark what
incident prompt this and I I know the
incident he's talking about and it was
significant uh I was there as well and
Five Towns lost a lot of their
structural firefighting gear and the
insurance carrier hasn't paid and as a
result I know that we we got hit we're
fortunate that would happened at the end
of our budgeting process so we could get
$50,000 from the town to replace it the
other four towns didn't get that and
they went without for almost an entire
year in fact it was an entire year they
went out with went out with equipment
they couldn't function anymore because
their budgets were done and they
couldn't get it replaced uh that's not
the only incident we've had my team
especially hasn't been paid for there's
been other incidents one incident almost
put us out of business because we never
got compensated for all of our loss and
the towns ate it there's another
incident we didn't get paid for and one
of the questions was what if it happens
at a home and we did have a home and
generally homeowners insurance covers
that uh but we had a renter no renters
insurance and we had to eat that and
that person fled the country so we're
never going to get that money and we had
to eat that as
well we we operate a team that goes from
Farmington all the way down to plastow
from Deerfield all the way over to
Portsmouth one of the larger
teams and the issue of not being paid
wounds us to the point that we can't
function anymore so we'll go without
until we do get paid or another bud
budget cycle comes along we often can
share stuff when we're in a jam with
other teams they can bail us out uh
that's generally how we survive by
begging and borrowing at
times generally we our most of our work
is uh fixed
facilities industrial and transportation
accidents the teams about 30 people each
Town contributes some help to it and
these team these teams are all trained
in as hattis materials
technicians the funding is tight it's
already on a shoestring we don't receive
any help from funding from the state
other than grants that are available and
we really our life blood is getting
reburst for our for our losses in any
damaged equipment
that's my that's my concern three times
now we haven't been paid and it's
injured the team's ability to respond as
a result of all that lost
equipment are these insurance companies
that are not paying you or is it um
individual the companies I I don't know
who is it that who is it that's supposed
to be paying most of our work is
insurance
companies okay there are times we we
have had to take the loss because there
was wasn't
Insurance okay um representative guber
and then
Penza uh thank you I used to oversee a
hazard material Department in Vermont I
understand your concerns the um the
insurance companies themselves which are
typically the places where you get
reimbursed is there another technique
that you could uh that could be done at
the state level with the insurance
commission for the insurance companies
to be forced them to pay these sort of
payments you I think I'll I'll wait for
the Portsmith Chief to answer that
question for you because he actually is
the president of the mutual Aid System I
work for him so he he deals with those
issues I think he'd probably answer the
question more appropriately is that fair
okay thank you thanks oh there's someone
else who's going to be speaking because
I don't have any more pink cards oh okay
just pass it around thank you uh
represent Penza yeah this might be a
question for the next speaker but um
just quickly it goes back to uh earlier
in your testimony um in regards with the
insurance piece so I just wanted to
understand that so you're saying that um
you guys are out uh fighting any of
these situations equipment gets damage
the insurance for these are you know
whatever it may be private entities or
whatever that are supposed to cover it
just don't end up paying most of the
time they pay some
don't that's what we're going through
right now actually one we have a
significant bill Bill very significant
Bill and we've not received payment yet
from the insurance company followup
followup I understand that this bill
will put you know emphasis because it's
higher penalties and stuff like that and
especially if it's going to let's say a
court case but this isn't necessarily
going to if someone's if someone's not
paying they're still not going to pay
like it it's obviously going to take
probably a matter of court to make them
do that correct
they generally pay uh this is to uh
entice them to pay sooner so we can be
made whole so we can get back up and
functioning
again thank you any other questions from
the
committee no seeing none thank you very
much for your coming in and talking to
us today and I now call William
mcquillin from SC
foad uh thank you madam chairman members
of the committee for record my name is
William mcquillin and I'm the uh
president of the SE Coast Chief Fire
officers Mutual Aid District which is
over on the Southeastern part of the
state and uh we have about 30 we have 36
New Hampshire cities and towns that uh
uh fire departments that are in the uh
Mutual Aid district and uh um we see
this as a vehicle to to help
municipalities especially those uh
smaller towns that are um you know sb2
towns and and have to wait for town
meeting to be able to to replace gear
and make these types of expenditures to
replace these things and we're looking
for a vehicle uh to to amend exist
existing law to to make it a little
easier for our our
folks okay any questions from the
committee representative Freeman thank
you madam chair and thank you for coming
in front of us I'm just curious what for
some of the conversation and some of the
testimony you've been live listening to
um there seem seems to be some issue
with insurance companies reimbursing you
in a timely fashion is that correct uh
thank you for the question and yes
that's the that's the the Crux of the
issue is carriers and ultimately who's
responsible thank you I may have a
followup absolutely thank you so much so
um given given this change in the law
how do you feel this would compel
insurance companies to pay
up uh again we we think that if there's
more of a uh more teeth there and that
they're not going to be paying out as
much money they'll be compelled to pay
quicker right that is that is the goal
here is to get them to pay quicker thank
you okay representative Miner thank you
madam chair and thank you for testifying
before us today so my question is if if
um an insurance company is not paying
there must be a reason why they're not
paying so apparently there's some
dispute as to the amount or or whether
in fact um theault lies on that
insurance company let's say can you
address uh address that
issue so thanks for the question and I
think it's a it's a case-by casee issue
right with respect to whether or not
carriers pay or when they don't pay or
whether or not there's a responsible
party for the release of the uh the the
material right so as uh as Chief
d'angeles explained there's been some
other circumstances that have have been
you know um encountered right so I can't
necessarily speak and say that it's a
it's all Financial or that it's all
insurance companies but you will agree
there's a dispute that's that's why the
insurance companies AR paying absolutely
there is a dispute yes one more question
one more question and is there an
opportunity to to um negotiate this
payment I mean is it is it all or
nothing is that is that how it works so
um again I don't uh I don't want to talk
specifics about anything that's going on
but I think um right like anything else
in this world right there's always room
to negotiate and talk and come to a a
resolution thank you yep representative
pateni you had your hand
up thank you madam chair Okay so earlier
the I think in the first testimony I
think the thing that was the worst part
of what the loophole needs to be fixed
but does this necessarily fix the
loophole where so for example somebody
owes
$50,000 they don't they're not paying
the $50,000 you know past 90 days
whatever it may be they pay the $1,000
and then they're off the hook for the
50,000 is that really fixing this I I
don't know if I see the connection
that's really what was talked about
so to I'm I'm not sure in your example
that that fixes the issue either right
and I don't believe I don't I don't
believe that's necessarily the case
right that you'd pay $1,000 fine over
$50,000 bill in your incident
right and that the way current law reads
it would be a $551,000 bill yeah right
okay all right I just want to make sure
no I'm hoping I'm answering your
question clarify just because it's
giving them I guess in a sense the
representative was talking about it
seems like it was giving them kind of an
out like they're they'll pay the, but
they still haven't paid the 50 so what
what are we gonna what can we do in a
sense to legislate for them to actually
pay the bill is is really what it comes
down to and would should we specifically
have something in here that's talking
about an outside Insurance Agency as
well instead of just general should we
get it more
specific again uh happy to happy to work
with the committee if uh right we we we
certainly are are willing to come up
with any kind of a solution
right good representative Scully thank
you Madame chair thanks for giving us
your
testimony do you know how many times a a
bill is sent to private homeowners after
a response and do you think this is is
appropriate to hit a private homeowner
with a hammer this big
so with respect to sending a bill to a
private homeowner I can tell you that um
I don't recall um ever having done it in
in my career all right in the last 35
years that I've been in the involved in
the fire
service follow up would you have any
objection and if we had some
exclusionary language in here to say
that homeowners would not be levied this
type of penalty
so I think it warrants discussion um in
that right if you're you're a homeowner
and you're storing something that's
covered by this law um I don't I don't
and and a fire department and a HazMat
team then has to do some type of
mitigation and cleanup right that uh
there has to be some responsibility of
the homeowner who brought these products
and then had them released somehow
right okay um well yes and and I do
understand you could build them for that
is this a private homeowner still this
is would be a very honorous penalty for
a private homeowner as opposed to a
business that should know better and
have better
practices
uh yeah most again homeowners homeowners
insurance um is typically who'd be
responsible here I think when when we're
talking uh I think some there are some
funds I know that are uh out there um uh
for for you know specifically around oil
tanks lit leaking basements and that
type of
thing
okay representative BBY so I I want to
get a a better sense of how the penalty
works now and how or or fails to work
now and how it would uh how you would
Envision it working and um so the way it
works as I understand it now uh there is
a penalty of $1,000 if someone does not
pay the bill
promptly and then they are no longer on
the hook for any further penalty and
whether you can get the $50,000 that is
actually owed is uh is a is is an open
question so you might end up only
getting $1,000 of penalty and no none of
the reimbursment for the 50,000 is that
is that the way it sometimes works in a
worst case
no I think the again the incentive here
the the intent not to speak for
representative cre but uh certainly our
intent was to try and get people to pay
the pay the bill quicker okay so so uh
and but I'm just talking about you know
how it's so that was my example of how
it fails under current law as opposed to
what the proposal is uh so it sounds
like the proposal is
to have 90 days of Le way and then have
$1,000 charged per of penalty per day
but that penalty would effectively be
paying off the uh that $50,000 bill so
after 50 days if they actually were
paying it then they'd be free and clear
or may or I guess there's a 20% pen
penalty on top of that so they'd be uh
free and clear after paying
um 50,000 plus 20% of that uh but it
would it would essentially put them on a
u payment schedule of $1,000 per day is
that what is that's what is intended and
is that do you think that would
work so to to speak to intent again I
think the intent here is to get people
to pay quicker right it's not
necessarily get them on a payment plan
um and as to whether or not it would
work um I I don't know okay I I I I
guess what I'm what I see here is a real
problem and I'm not sure that the
solution is the way that it's the
solution that's proposed is actually
going to get to the goal of making the
payments come through quicker and making
sure they come through and I'm wondering
if there might be some other models out
there for uh penalties for non-payment
that might in fact provide provide a
better model again happy happy to work
with the the committee right work
session whatever you you require to to
to get to a solution that's uh um you
know acceptable to you thank you thank
you yeah representative
ktoa thank you madam chair and thank you
for taking my question I keep looking at
this and I'm looking at the
RSA and I'm looking at the line H that
it's going to replace and what nowhere
on that line does it say for repayment
it says that currently it's a one-time
penalty plus interest
acre may be assessed for
non-payment so what you're saying this
bill the way it's written is $11,000 per
day plus
interest maybe assessed after 90 days of
non-payment it doesn't have anything
about paying a bill this is just for non
not even paying so my question to you is
if this is to pay a bill why we be
having these fines because your your
your intent is for them to pay the bill
but having it as making a fine above the
bill that's what you're
asking okay so I just so they still have
to pay
$50,000 and then they have to pay $1,000
per
day after 90
days and they keep until they pay the
50,000 and then and whatever the th000 a
day is so if they didn't pay for 50 days
they owe you
$100,000 plus 20% Which be $10,000 so on
a $50,000 Bill they're going to have to
pay you 110,000 is that my
understanding okay
okay any other questions from the
committee huh oh I'm sorry
representative wheeler I thought you
were pointing s oh yeah sorry about that
my angled hand I apologize Madam chair
uh thank you for taking my
question um my question is if somebody
was harboring or hosting or holding
something in their house that was
significant enough to represent a hazard
danger don't you think that that is
extraordinary enough in itself to cause
responsibility could you elaborate on
what things might cause within a private
home a hazard danger and and the what
that represents for the officers going
to that house thank you for the question
represent I think the the the that's the
issue is that uh uh we really have no
idea what people are doing in their
homes uh right and that uh often times
by the time that we get called we we we
encounter things that are are quite
expected um certainly um our HazMat team
has has gone to things where uh you know
folks have been um mixing chemicals you
know uh experimenting right that then
caused a a serious danger to our folks
and to themselves and to the uh the area
around them right whether it's uh could
even be explosives it could be right
chemicals right whatever it is we get
called to try and mitigate it and and
and to to to make it less hazardous to
the environment so I think to your point
uh representative right we don't know
what people are doing uh in in their own
homes and uh if somebody has called us
and it's serious enough for for us to
take action I think it warrants some uh
uh some
fine okay any other type of behavior any
other representative Bixby yeah I'm just
just on that topic of you don't NE
necessarily know what's there so that
might be a reason not to create an
exemption and on one thing that comes to
mind is that you might not know was
there was say um an illicit meth lab and
you wouldn't want to create an exemption
for that
right okay thank
you you know of
any okay any other questions from the
committee thank you so very much I
appreciate your your testimony this
afternoon thank you all for your time
appreciate it uh any other members wish
to to
uh anybody else wish to present a pink
card seeing none may I have the blue
sheet for uh this uh HB
179 and let's
see and we have online we had 11 people
support this legislation one person
oppose on the pink on the blue sheet
here we have two people in support with
that I'm going to close public hearing
on HB
179 there you
go okay moving right
along and we're not too badly out of
time
here thank you thank you thank you okay
I'm going
to open up the hearing for HB
171 establishing a moratorium on the
issuance of permits for new
landfills and if I may just take a
moment I'd like to get a copy of the
bill that's up
there oh you have it okay thank
you all right good and uh today to uh
present uh introduce this bill to our
committee is represented our our one and
only representative Nicholas
ger welcome back thank you very much
it's good to be
back um thank you for the record uh I'm
representative Nick gerana I represent
chesher 15 which is Chesterfield
Hinsdale Kean Wards 1 and 3 through five
Su Walpole and
westerland I left my copy of the bill up
there but um I have distributed my
written
testimony Madam chair and honorable
colleagues last year this committee
passed a moratorium on new landfills and
put it on the consent calendar and it is
still a good idea in November of last
year JL car issued a preliminary
objection to the new landfill sighting
rules sighting concerned concerns that
the proposed rules were inadequate in
key respects and would leave New
Hampshire significantly behind other
states in the region and across the
country and around the world in the
protections they offer granted Staters
in December the Department of
Environmental Services returned to JL
car to represent the rules
unchanged our colleagues on that
committee reiterated their concerns but
felt strongly that there was no further
ground for Action from a rules committee
instead they urged the legislature to
address these concerns through policy
action this moratorium will give us the
time to do exactly that
the primary concern raised by opponents
of HB 171 is the assertion that a
moratorium could result in a capacity
shortfall this is not the case such
concerns are based on the assumption
that the turnkey facility in Rochester
does not apply for an expansion when its
current permit expires in
2034 The Operators of that facility
however have stated publicly that they
intend to do so we still also have the
mount carbury landfill in Success New
Hampshire which is permitted to receive
Municipal Solid Waste until at least
2041 and Dees estimates or as of 2022
estimated that at the current fill rate
that facility may have capacity until
2043 it is also critically important to
point out that this is and this is the
most powerful argument in support of a
moratorium that de's projection for
landfill Capac capacity need is based on
New Hampshire's solid waste
needs and yet we continue to import
nearly 50% of what we landfill from out
of
state one piece of testimony with regard
to HB
2115 asserted that there is an
approaching C capacity crisis in New
England well there is no capacity
shortfall let alone crisis in New
Hampshire our statutes do not require us
to become The Dumping Ground for the
Region's trash and our constituents have
made themselves clear time and again
that it is not the granite state that
they want to live in unless and until we
do our job as a legislature and take
take action to address this critical
issue we should not be considering
opening another landfill that is not
needed for New Hampshire's solid waste
needs our new governor has openly
expressed her concerns about these
issues and with this new alignment of
interests between this body and the
governor we are in excellent position to
take meaningful action we have several
pieces of good legislation for
consideration this year but we do not
have a bill currently before us that
will address the problem of out of-state
waste now is the time to press pause
when capacity need is not an issue and
address concerns with the new landfill
sighting rules and the problem of outof
State waste I thank you for your time
and consideration and I am very happy to
answer
questions questions representative
King thank you madam chair thank you for
testifying on this
bill assuming we were to enact a
moratorium and assuming we ran out of
space in state would there be options
for us to send our um Municipal Solid
Waste out of state and where would other
states like Massachusetts send their
waste if they no longer had an
opportunity to send it here here thank
you for the question representative i i
i neither know nor particularly care
where Massachusetts would send their
waste if it's not here um and currently
we export about 10% of our waste uh so
there are um you know with some of our
border towns there is some Solid Waste
going into neighboring states I imagine
that would increase a little bit but
other states unlike us have been very
very specific about developing
regulations particularly around the kind
of waste to it's important to
distinguish between the amount and the
kind of waste for example uh in a number
of other states I believe both in in
Vermont and and Massachusetts you can't
landfill mattresses for example uh you
can landfill mattresses here they send
their mattresses here to landfill so
it's important to consider also when
we're talking about what New Hampshire
waste goes out of state there are things
that we can't send into to mass
Massachusetts Vermont or Maine uh that
we do actually take uh in return because
they have regulations in place that we
do not excellent thank you
representative gerna um so with your
reference to um items like mattresses
and so forth um the this I do want to
make it known that the solid waste
working group is working on um you know
investigating programs where it would be
viable for us to not landfill those
things but in in ways to deconstruct
them and recycle the parts and all sorts
of things and it's it's not only just
mattresses but there are other items
that we are looking at but to the other
uh the other question that had come up
regarding
um if we had a moratorium and at some
point needed ran out of space to have
our trash sent to or you know put put in
and we would have to send that trash out
of state somewhere what do you believe
would be the cost to our municipalities
in the event that that should
happen thank you very much first of all
Madam chair for the point about the work
that the solid waste working group uh is
doing so it's really great that we took
the action we did earlier so uh and also
I know concern around you know Plastics
and other things that we really need to
divert so I appreciate the work that
that group is doing I mean on some
extent I'm going to push back a little
bit against the the question because I'm
not really prepared to concede the idea
that it's a danger of running out of
capacity need um so I you know I'll I'll
kind of stake my ground there that that
that question is fair enough is uh
raises issues that I don't think are
going to happen Okay uh representative
ktoa and then
Bixby thank you madam chair and thank
you
representative for this bill um I do
have a question for you I just went to
um heard about our housing shortage in
New Hampshire um and it's a it's a big
deal and if we added another 100 to
200,000 people to the state of New
Hampshire in the next five
years that is going to increase our
waste how are we going to handle
that thank you I appreciate that
question uh to kind of take it in two
parts first I I think growth
on that scale is and I don't mean this
with any disrespect but I I think is
highly unlikely for a variety of reasons
including we don't have the workforce to
build on that scale presently so you
know I I would love to see housing build
up but it will be on a longer scale uh
and we'll be prepared to deal with that
uh the other part of my answer to your
question representative has to do with
we have to address outof State waste so
uh if we address outof State waste uh
our ability to deal with more waste
produced within the states is going to
grow uh and and I think in a very
manageable way given probably the scale
that we could even hope to see housing
increase representative comto
followup and and thank you for that
question and I know that the numbers I
gave were pretty pretty large but um you
know I'm looking at debris from building
and things like that so there is waste
uh associated with building new homes
and things like that
but the other question is is you know
one of the things that we've always
talked about and I thought I understood
but I was really enlightened when I went
on a a field trip last year with to
TurnKey
um was
that TurnKey is a private
facility so although they have to take
our waste until
2034 we cannot tell them where to as
long as they can meet our capacity we
cannot tell a private company where they
can or cannot take waste from is that
correct
there is debate I thank you for the
question and it's an excellent question
we had a bill last year obviously in
this committee that would say 15% is is
a cap there there is a debate about how
far you can test the interstate commerce
clause and when I when I served on a
study committee we had someone from the
Attorney General's office come in and
they said there are grounds on which you
can challenge the interstate commerce CL
so uh it's an excellent question it is
an open legal question about whether or
not we could drw a line like that thank
you representative Bixby you had a
question um yeah I I I'm just getting
wanted to get back to the capacity issue
and so um if we so uh we I think we
heard earlier today that uh the
permitted capacity for um TurnKey is up
through
3034 and or 20
2034 and and uh I believe that
um uh which is five years after the
moratorium would end uh do you know what
the capacity at uh Mount carbury is uh
or how long that how long that is good
for they are thank you for the question
they are and and perhaps representative
pens has some more information but I
will say uh based on the 2122 banial
Solid Waste report they are permitted to
provide capacity to 2041 and as of that
report as they said Dees had estimated
based on fill rates that it could be
extended at least a couple years to 2043
with current fill rates so 2041
potentially 2043 follow up sure follow
up so it sounds like um we have plenty
of capacity to have a moratorium go
until uh
2030 uh and um just to clarify this is
only this this pum is only on completely
new uh landfills it doesn't have to do
with uh with expansions so if uh it
would not get in the way of TurnKey
starting to submit their application for
an expansion thank you for that
clarifying question that's absolutely
right it does not apply to expansions
and as you said The Operators of TurnKey
have said publicly that they intend to
apply for an expansion and that process
would begin soon because it does take a
little while so yes between uh TurnKey
and mount carbury we will continue to
have capacity well beyond 2030 okay
thank
you uh representative Penza then
Howard thank you madam chair and just to
follow up on that in regards with
TurnKey because I've had Direct
conversations with Waste Management
about that they would actually start the
process not that soon so I just want
that to be clear um they were saying
that would be 2028 and and uh 2029 is
when they would start that process and
that's what I've heard have you heard
the saying that's really the numbers
that we're looking at here for when they
would um start working on their
application for an
expansion thank you I hadn't heard those
specific years but I know that it would
relatively soon it's all relative right
but uh they would want to do it a number
of years ahead of that 24 2034 date but
so that sounds right to me followup sure
and during this time for morat do you
believe that we can start really looking
at um cuz you know landfills are the
bottom of the barrel they're they're
literally what we should be the last
resort that we could actually spend our
time and focus on on other different
types of unbelievable Technologies with
Recycling incineration and all those
things that we haven't even looked at in
the state at this point yes absolutely
and we've heard some good uh examples
here like with the solid waste working
group the uh food waste diversion which
is starting next month that was a good
first step uh the chair has spoken about
the work that they're doing thinking
about say mattresses and some other
things that we want to stop landfilling
and there are a wide variety of
technological possibilities and policy
possibilities that a moratorium would
allow us to
explore representative Howard and then
Gruber thank you madam chair um well
last session we talked a little bit
about um a moratorium on private
applications and
exploring more publicly held um
landfills would would would that be
something that that you would
consider or or on all landfills is
it thank you very much representative so
the the moratorium uh last year and this
moratorium are across the board public
and private the other piece that we
talked about last year was the idea that
all landfills going forward would be
publicly owned and leased to a private
operator if it was the state
a county um so those are kind of two
separate issues uh but in this case the
moratorium would would apply across the
board representative guber uh yes just
want to follow up one more moment on
capacity because I understand you did
not mention other landfills that could
be expanded such as the Lebanon landfill
um some of other sites and second Point
um is that my understanding our
diversion goals are 25% by 2030 so that
actually do you think this would
actually help push us towards those
diversion goals thank you very much
representative it's important to point
out Lebanon is is a public facility and
it has a very it is um what's the word
I'm looking for um they're they don't
they're not open to all sources
specifically for Lebanon maybe what
contracts they have there so they that
that doesn't count in terms of of
meeting capacity need for the state as
as a whole but to your second question
yes I I I think that diversion which is
supposed to be driving our Solid Waste
Management plan the the very purpose of
the moratorium is to to force us to
really aggressively take on the issue of
diversion representative Ken thank you
again Madam
chair I'm of the strong contention that
the Silver Bullet of landfills is waste
energy plants incineration plants my
concern with a moratorium is that you
know it could take a few years to get
the Investments to build the waste
energy plant and in order for waste
energy plants to be
viable um financially for the
municipalities you know to to spend
their tipping fees at a waste of energy
plant instead of a landfill we have to
we have to get rid of landfills as an
option and my concern is that with a
moratorium of only 5 years that
municipalities or businesses will be
they'll feel disinclined to want to make
that capital investment in waste energy
plants because they'll think well the
moratorium is almost up here in a couple
years uh and then we can they'll just
want to go right back to you know
landfills and then all this money that
we put into the waste energy plant is
going to go bankrupt and I'm just
wondering how you feel about the idea of
instead of a moratorium just a or excuse
me a temporary
moratorium um an indefinite moratorium
where now it sends a signal to everybody
who would be an investor in um a waste
of energy plant that yes we mean this
for reals and you will have you will
have the requisite trash needed to make
the waste energy PL financially viable
what are your thoughts thank you
representative I see the The Five-Year
moratorium as a policy tool it gives us
the option to explore a variety of
options while having press pause right
so when it comes to considerations about
waste to energy for example uh this is a
time period in which potential investors
can explore that landscape and decide
whether or not it is something that that
they want to invest in and and there are
a whole set of other policy
possibilities that we could explore so
uh it's important to point out that that
is the specific purpose of this
moratorium is to provide us a window of
time where we have a pause to explore
multiple options follow up followup
could you see that towards the end of
the the time frame of this moratorium
that instead we either um expand the
date of the moratorium or make it
indefinite at the End of This this term
thank you for the question I don't want
to speculate on that it's certainly
always a possibility uh but I don't want
to speculate as to what we might do in
2028 or 2029 with a moratorium okay
thank you any other questions
representative Barber thank you madam
chair thank you representative I have a
question regarding the bill um would it
be possible to add a mechanism to the
bill that would require an exploratory
committee to research alternatives
right in the bill rather than taking to
chance that that would actually
happen thank you very much
representative we've actually had uh a
number of study committees already uh on
this issue I was on one representative
eel referred to one a few years ago that
she was on Madame chair has referred to
the work of the solid waste working
group and they are often making
recommendations again our food waste
diversion which is going in next week
would came out of the work of the solid
waste working group um so I don't see
the need for a study committee such as
you describe I think a lot of that work
has already been done and now it's our
responsibility to enact it in
legislation any other
questions seeing none thank you so much
uh for introducing that bill and
fielding all those questions um I now
call Representative Terry
Spar you've requested two minutes
good afternoon uh I'm representative
Terry Spar and uh I just wanted to share
with you my perspective and uh sort of
echoing representative ger yes
practically half of uh you know waste in
our landfills here in New Hampshire is
imported from surrounding states and uh
why is that uh because the big players
in the business have made the rules at
the very expense of New Hampshire
citizens and this this isn't the be the
benign trash that uh we had 70 years ago
this trash these days is full of
volatile organic chemicals or compounds
excuse me pasas toxic chemicals and more
uh in Massachusetts and Vermont you
can't landfill rugs as was mentioned and
uh the reason being is because they've
got pasas in them uh but guess where you
can dump them right here it's wrong and
uh all this trash will be stewing in
these landfills for decades
uh and may eventually leech at some
point into their
waterways uh these landfills May well
very be uh very excuse me may very well
become Future Super fund sites we just
don't know
that uh I I I just how can to me how
could any New Hampshire resident of
sound mine aware of this issue support
any action that will jeopardize
themselves or their you know their their
future generations and their
families uh why uh should we residents
suffer while few people take advantage
of us and reap in the millions of
dollars we must stop all new
landfills uh landfill permits as uh the
bill proposes encap our incoming waste
from outside States the current excuse
me the current trajectory is a disaster
it's wrong and it hurts every resident
of this great state we're not protecting
our citizens and uh we are certainly not
making New Hampshire any stronger thank
you any questions represent Penza I'm
not sure if you if you said it or I
missed it can you tell me where you what
what district do you represent Grafton
County uh Hanover lime area right near
the Lebanon dump oh wonderful can I have
a followup um I was lucky to visit the
that landfill which is um seems to be a
really good balance and design and of
course they're only taking in New
Hampshire just because it's got the
public piece to it um have you spent any
time in researching at all uh that LE
Phil uh I have not personally we used to
uh take our uh waste there and then we
went to a service
recently representative M King thank you
madam chair thank you for taking
questions you bring up an interesting
point um which is uh the topic of pasas
so you know in New Hampshire we might
have bans on um let's say we enacted
some bans on what could be disposed of
in our landfills but um do you believe
that we would still be open to ex so
like let's say we um we prevent P from
being sold in in um in our products in
New Hampshire but products containing
pasas in other states would potentially
still be dumped here and it might be an
item like like a rug that you said we
don't have a ban on rugs but because our
rugs don't have P their out ofate rugs
do have past and now we're inadvertently
getting past into our landfills is that
is that what you're saying um I I you
know I I went to the soil waste working
group on Friday and uh you know we
absolutely have to do a better job of
recycling and uh I don't know um where
uh you know past rules are and
regulations and and but I certain I know
we the the I think the FED just got uh
got rid of two different ones or
something but uh we I we shouldn't have
pfest in our in our in our materials and
our products I just and whether that's
just new Hamp and we go that route
that's fine but I don't think that we
absolutely shouldn't have it be you know
disposed of in our
state any other
questions seeing none thank you
today call John Swan from safe Forest
Lake up in Dalton
good afternoon Madam chair and uh
members of the committee thank you for
allowing me to speak today in support of
House Bill 171 uh my name is John Swan
I'm the founder of save Forest Lake and
I need to preface my testimony by
stating that in order to not get sued by
cassella for third time I need you to
understand that all of this is my
opinion based on my research and
experience um I also did want to point
out for the record that online uh
testimony it looks like 259 citizens
signed in in support of this uh very
important piece of
legislation um I did send my testimony
with a supportive documents to the
committee I hope you received that had a
chance to take a look at it because
there's a lot of good stuff in there
relative to why we need this um landfill
moratorium
um several times I've heard already uh
the word crisis brought up and that's a
that's a very good word and I like the
conversation that's been going on this
is something that can continue during
this moratorium when we decide what
we're going to do we have a lot of smart
people on this state including on the
solid waste working group who could be
tasked with working on this etc etc
however I want to point out that we have
a fantastic
opportunity to prevent a future crisis
in fact there's no time machine needed
to go back in time and stop it we can
stop the proposed Granite State landfill
in Dalton and Bethlehem at Douglas Drive
next to Forest Lake we have the
opportunity with this moratorium to get
it
right I brought a friend with me today
not really friend but someone I've grown
very intimate with over the course of
the six years this is a a map a drawing
of the NCS landfill in
Bethlehem and the uh the mapping is from
the uh July 2024 Tri anual groundwater
monitoring report uh provided to Dees by
Sanborn head on behalf of cassella NCS
the markups on there are mine and I just
want to show this is a 30-year-old
landfill in Bethlehem it has grown and
grown over the course of 30 years when
cassella first bought this small little
um pretty much local Municipal landfill
uh back in uh 1993 94 they touted it as
a state-of-the-art landfill that they
would be building in fact they bragged
about Excavating the old unlined
landfill that is here in the uh stage
two it shows right there approximate
extent of former unlined landfill in the
Box over stage two so they excavated
that put that into the new stage one
area and then Dees and cassella
everybody involved blessed the
excavation you got all the
contamination build stage two so it was
approved and yet
today this is the July 2024 tri-annual
groundwater report this is my markup on
there these are posos detections
according to the report from Sanborn
head submitted to Dees this is what we
have the opportunity to prevent from
being recreated six miles away next to
Forest Lake State Park as you can see
according to the data provided and most
people don't like to read the reports
because they're very long and they're
very entailed I've had to learn how to
read science scientific
data of the uh Wells there were 19 Wells
um that had a total of 107 total
different Posas compounds
detected eight of those had exceedence
of the ambient groundwater quality
standard or
aqs I also would want to point out that
this entire landfill is cited
within the Watershed of the AMC River
which is right here
it all flows northward to the AMC
River there was a 78% increase in total
posos levels from prior 2023 2024
testing at 12 Wells that had prior
testing I went through and did the math
78% increase that's pretty
significant and I will add that both
Dees and the owner operator and Sanborn
head have relied on the the story The
Alibi I call it that it's the old
unlined landfill that is causing Mr
contamination yes could you please uh
direct your comments to the idea of
establishing a moratorium yes okay
basically what I'm trying to say is that
this would be the same owner operator
Engineers contractors building a new
landfill that's not needed nor not
wanted it's not wanted and
we have a great opportunity here with
this moratorium to get it right as
representative King spoke to there's
opportunity for other technologies that
could be utilized we have smart people
in the room who can solve this problem
but please this moratorium gives us an
opportunity we don't need a time machine
to go back and fix the problem we can
why is this not being remediated right
now in
fact this mailer from Cass sent to the
North Country touts keeping us safe in
the North Country this is a relatively
new mailer yet this speaks differently
so the point of the moratorium and the
PO point of my testimony is that we need
to learn from the mistakes of the past
this is like St gobain wanting another
facility somewhere in the North Country
would we allow it knowing what we know
about St go Bain today no and why is
this not being mitigated in fact I have
gone into the AMC River three times now
there is a seep at this
location it's like a small waterfall
cascading into the AMC River I've tested
it three times I waited across tested it
uh last year in October or 2023 in
October twice in 2024 June and August
all three lab reports came back for the
same four to five posos compounds in
that water cascading off of the NCS
property into the AMC
River yet the department still does not
require that surface runoff going into
the Amon River to be tested I'm the only
one that's tested
it so perhaps you can ask the department
another question why aren't they
requiring that surface water runoff
going off of the property into the AMC
River why is that not being tested for
posos and whatever contaminants that
could be in there it's the same four to
five posos including pooa so and that is
uh EPA deemed that a hazardous compound
last April so again the point is let's
learn from history and I think uh we
don't need to reward a uh owner operator
with a new landfill when we have an
opportunity to get it right next time if
we even need another landfill so thank
you thank you any questions from the
committee seeing none thank you for your
testimony and I call Nat
Grace from
Bia thank you madam chair n Grace uh for
the business and industry Association
the uh Statewide Chamber of Commerce we
oppose this
legislation um I I at the
prompting of the chair's question about
the Statewide working group I should add
that I probably should have added
another sentence to my letter uh after
the first sentence um just basically
noting that different policy Decisions
by legislators uh by the legislature
will determine whether or not uh we have
our capacity estimate of 2034 is correct
or not um it's possible that in addition
to
decreasing um capacity based on
something like soil standards for p
which may require landfilling of soil um
other options such as you know Banning
carpets or um as legislation this year
uh would do uh removing some paint from
the uh from the waist stream would
increase that capacity by some some
amount so I just want to make sure that
was clear on the record that that that
2034 number I do recognize that's just
an estimate um the other thing I want to
point out on the capacity side of things
uh is that uh Dees is permitting also
has a max intake um so even if some
facilities are allowed to continue to
take waste past 2034 past uh whenever
kind of we hit the break even Point here
um that that doesn't mean that's going
to meet all of the need of for the waste
generated in New Hampshire the same
level capacity um and I I do want to
point out that the capacity question is
really a regional question um and it's
really a Cost question because even if
it ends up being the case that you know
we in New Hampshire have to export more
waste the ultimate question is well how
much is that going to cost people who
throw away things um while we can
certainly take uh make policy decisions
that reduce uh the need for landfilling
if we're landfilling and it turns out
that we're having to truck that out to
Ohio or something uh you know that's
going to add additional costs um that's
part of the calculus
here um and and part of the business
analysis that waste disposal companies
do when they look at you know are we
going to open a facility like a mattress
recycling facility or are we going to uh
apply for a new landfill so that's all
part of that overall calculus that I
want to make sure I pointed out um which
goes to kind of the overall concern we
have here is not only in the timing and
the capacity but the ultimate question
here of the cost and and the cost of
businesses um which obviously produce um
produce uh land fillable materials um
and how much that may increase depending
on exactly how the uh what policy
decisions are made I hope that was clear
I'm certainly happy to take questions if
the committee has any represent Bixby
then M yes so you bring up the point
that uh solid waste disposal is a reason
Regional issue uh however I I guess one
of the things that I'm wondering is if
all of the states around us have put
bans on particular things going into
their landfills why should New Hampshire
take the burden
of uh of taking on the trash from the
states that have banded in their own
States I it's is is that does not seem
like a good business proposition for New
Hampshire well I I think that's a
different issue than the one in front of
you you know if you want to ban certain
materials from going into a landfill
that's different than an overall banon
landfills um so to use our favorite
example P um much of that uh is being
shipped to Canada for landfilling at the
moment um if Canada decides they're not
taking um sludge sorry much of the
sludge collected from wastewater
treatment facilities which contains p is
being sent to Canada for land filling at
the moment um if Canada decides to ban
the import of sludge um that has to go
somewhere else um it cannot be for
instance land applied in Maine um
because Maine has banned that um so if
we make a policy decision like uh Maine
is was to make uh which results in a
change in how we handle that product um
that's a different question than well
can someone open a landfill or
not okay representative Miner was next
sorry thank you madam chairman it's
interesting uh one of your last comments
was the cost of disposing of um all
these materials that are coming from out
of state but correct me if I'm wrong the
cost doesn't go to the company the cost
goes to us we we pay for we pay for the
disposal it's it's not like the it's not
like these large corporations are losing
money they're in fact making
money I is there a question there yes
I'm sorry do you agree with that
statement well I don't disagree I mean
if you're a company you're in the
business of making money and if it's the
cheapest place to put the land fillable
materials is New Hampshire then that's
where you're going to ship them I mean
that's just basic economics thank you
okay um representative Howard was
next thank you Madam chair um
so waste management is a is a profitable
business I I imagine and and this your
concern about costs has to do with your
bottom line so the fact that we that we
are taking garbage from around the the
way that you make your highest profit is
taking garbage from the New England
region so do you I I we spoke to you
know we had a Bia um person come last
session to talk to us about this too and
what I failed to ask her is what I want
to ask you and is that that is are all
business opportunities
equal I'm not sure what you mean by that
question I
mean profit at any at any cost or at any
you know is is that is that does that
sit well with you as an organization and
well so the point I was trying to make
which I don't think necessarily
articulated clearly but maybe a more
personal example will make sense is you
know I live in conquered we have a pay
as you throw system um where we buy
purple plastic bags from the grocery
store and you you pay based on how much
you throw out right um and that cost is
negotiated between conquered and the
waste disposal company and that cost is
based on what the waste the various
waste disposal companies bid for for
that so kind of at a residential level
that cost is in large part dictated by
what we do with our our trash so in
conquered it goes to the wheeler plant
they burn it um but you know in other
places it ends up in different landfills
throughout the state but if it's the
case that we that the states surrounding
us uh are not making policies that allow
them to landfill
um enough even to take exports from us
if we run out of capacity for New
Hampshire needs then if it turns out
that my trash uh you know has to end up
getting shipped to Ohio that cost is
going to be probably larger than it is
to get shipped up to Penacook and burned
but would we have to ship it to Ohio if
we just stop taking Maine and Vermont
and Massachusetts trash well I think
that goes to the question of you know
what can we do at the com Clause I'm I'm
not prepared to answer that
today representative
Penza uh thank you madam chair
so I'm trying to understand a couple
things first um can we just on the
record is uh Cella have a membership
with Bia so they pay dues to you I
believe that's the case Okay as well as
Waste Management I believe that's the
case Okay um we have that all online by
the way it's on our side under our our
just I'd love it for everybody to know
for the record um also
how how are costs going to go up when we
right now have more than 50% capacity
that's available for New Hampshire how
are costs going up if we actually are
putting New Hampshire TR first which by
the way is in every permit are you
familiar with that that they have to
take New Hampshire New Hampshire has to
be the number one priority are you
familiar with that I'm
famar with the basic outlines of the
permitting process I don't have an
in-depth knowledge of
that so where is the costs going to go
up I don't understand it's kind of like
you have a circular argument and it's
not resonating with me how are costs
going to go up when we wouldn't have to
send any of our trash out we have more
than 50% of capacity that's available
designated to New Hampshire so tell me
how costs are going up and the sky is
going to fall and you keep saying the
word ban this isn't a ban this is a till
2030 so I want to go back to an earlier
question you asked a prior witness uh
where you pointed out that I believe it
was one of the facilities um were
considering would be considering
application for expansion in 2028 or
2029 uh which is and
their if I understood correctly their
current uh allowed uh their current
permit goes to 2034 which is a year
period so the concern isn't
necessarily that there's
um a the concern is that because it
takes time um to go through the pering
process approximately six years if I did
that math correctly um for an expansion
I assume that a new landfill would take
longer than that um but because it takes
such a long period of time um if you
have a pause C
for the length of time that this bill
proposes you end up in a situation where
the max intake that the currently that
the existing landfills can take is
exceeded by the uh actual volume of land
fillable materials generated in the
state of New Hampshire and so the
question is what happens with that extra
and who pays for that and so that's
where I'm getting the cost argument is
well if the extra ends up having to get
shipped again I'm just I'm just uh you
know making it hard for people in Ohio
if it has to get shipped to Ohio you
know that cost of shipment is probably
going to be higher whether that's via
truck whether that's via train than it
is to go to someplace closer
um again it it depends on exactly what
happens in the regulatory structure but
that's where I'm where I'm basing my
cost argument if that's helpful
representative okay representative Bixby
yes thank you for taking my question so
um as a as a member of the New Hampshire
uh legislature it is my job to look out
for residents of New Hampshire and
businesses in New Hampshire not
businesses in Massachusetts or
Connecticut or Vermont and
the way that our
um that our statue is written in terms
of landfill capacity New Hampshire trash
has priority at the landfill uh at
and uh waste management is required to
have uh that capacity through 2034 at
TurnKey Mount carbury is required to
have that capacity through
2040 if it looks like they won't be able
to meet that capacity for New Hampshire
trash they have to take less out of
state
trash why should I as someone who's
watching out for New Hampshire
businesses and New Hampshire res
residents care if a Massachusetts
business or Massachusetts residents have
to send their trash to Ohio I don't see
how how is that a benefit for New
Hampshire to watch out for the people of
new of
Massachusetts well thank you for the
question representative Bixby um just to
be clear my testimony is limited to
businesses operating in New Hampshire
that's who I represent I don't represent
businesses in Massachusetts whether or
not they have to ship their trash
somewhere else is totally irrelevant to
what I'm paid to care about um and I
would assume that as a representative uh
in the legislature that you represent
your
constituents thank you representative H
Haskins thank you madam chair I'm sure
that you've heard a lot of the testimony
today would you agree that um there are
concerns that have been raised about a
variety of issues for our landfills for
our
waterways um whether we're accepting
materials that the states around us
don't accept where the p is coming from
where it's going do you think that a
to consider some of these very important
issues is
unreasonable well let me frame it this
way we've had numerous study committees
as we've heard today over the past more
than a decade um we've had the solid
waste working group working on this
problem and we haven't come up with a
solution yet I don't believe that a
pause is going to result in a solution
um it's just going to uh limit our
options going forward followup
followup are you aware that um a permit
is has already been worked up for the
past six years and and this pause would
not keep that permit um it would not
require that permit to start from
scratch an awful lot of work has been
done and
overall I'm hearing about shipping trash
to Ohio New Hampshire doesn't have a
capacity problem that has been
demonstrated through all the meetings
that I've participated in so we have to
get some of these red herrings off the
table we need the pause because we've
got issues that haven't been resolved
not that we haven't been working on them
but we haven't gotten to the point we
need to be in order to be secure that we
can safely take New Hampshire's trash
and not the surrounding states who are
sending the materials that are toxic to
New Hampshire
residents I don't know if there was a
question in there thank you for the
question I I am aware of kind of the
grandfathering process with permitting
thank you any other questions seeing
none thank you very much for your
testimony this afternoon and I call
Wayne
Morrison uh who's asked to speak for
five minutes but if you if you uh have
heard something already said that you
were planning on saying um please
refrain from repeating
it representative wheeler if you'd like
to take your seat you
may oh okay absolutely thank you sure
thank you for the record my name is
Wayne Morrison and I am president of an
organization called North Country
Alliance for balance speak closer to the
thank you um I want to start my
testimony uh cheer Aaron and uh
representative Jama and all of you I
want to thank you we've been at this for
six years and this is the most
constructive detailed meaningful
conversation I have heard at any point
about the solid waste problems in the
state of New Hampshire so I I applaud
you for your willingness to weit into
what is a complicated and sometimes
controversial issue and uh I am more
optimistic now than ever before in part
because this body has been willing to
wait in and try and make a
difference um I have testimony that I'm
sending around I won't read
it but I would like to highlight a few
points at various points this morning we
talked about um things like uh how much
waste is generated in the state of New
Hampshire and uh representative ktoa
mentioned and I know there's an inti
there's a big housing uh problem and
we're trying to do something about it
but in a reality check would be the
state of New Hampshire's population has
been relatively flat for the last eight
years the amount of trash we generate in
the state is roughly a million tons it's
maybe a little bit more a little bit
less but you you you can hear all kinds
of things about a crisis Isis in the
state of New Hampshire around trash it
absolutely is not the
case in fact if you were in business and
you had this kind of a flat
demand situation you would feel
incredibly you you would have an
incredibly efficient process to handle
it because you can pretty much guarantee
how much you're going to see every year
the wild card is unfortunately we take
in almost the same amount from out of
state and to my recollection and to in
our review that amount of trash is going
to go up the conversation about Ohio has
nothing to do with New Hampshire by the
way Massachusetts doesn't just send us
their trash they send their trash on
railroad cars to Ohio to Pennsylvania to
South uh Carolina uh they they've made a
decision the literally the train has
left the station in Massachusetts they
have decided rather than deal with that
problem they'll they'll make it somebody
else's problem and because we're a
neighboring state and because we haven't
acted sooner we're a magnet for
it and what I've heard that today is the
the I heard words today that we echoed
three and four years ago and I can't
tell you how rewarding it is to finally
hear representatives of the people
starting to see the same issues that we
have
seen I also want to talk a little bit
about the solid waste
plan Karen eel is a hero to me she went
into a she took on a very complicated
ated task with a committee that was made
up mainly with people in Industry who
have a financial interest in fighting
any progress on this subject and she has
been able to make
progress that plan the overarching goal
of that plan that was handed down by the
legislature was to set an aggressive
goal you've heard the number 25%
reduction by
2030 what that means in real waste is
375,000 tons if we were able to deliver
it that's the equivalent of eliminating
almost every any landfill in the state
except the waste management one and
TurnKey that's how much trash that is
that would eliminate the need for one
landfill if we ever hit the 45% by 2050
that's 675,000 tons it's an enormous you
know that's that's what we should be
aiming
at and the reason that's important
is that plan was developed less than two
years
ago why on Earth would we not let that
team that's done good work we're just
starting the composting initiative is
just
starting why would we ever issue a new
permit for a new landfill and
institutionalize the same thing that
we're trying to
stop I haven't spoken to anybody in in
the legislature or in the public I I
grew up in Massachusetts I have friends
in Massachusetts nobody thinks what
we're doing makes any sense all we need
is the backbone and the willingness to
wait in and do something about it we
keep hearing about the interstate
commerce
clots that is an obstacle it's not the
end of the story other states have
figured out how to get around it we do
not have to hire private companies to
run our
landfills and our goal should be I I
believe our goal should really be uh if
we're successful to push out as far as
possible ever having to have another
landfill in the state of New Hampshire
and that's doable it's not a pipe dream
it's not some tree hugger telling you
something that we can't live with we can
do that but rather than pouring
infrastructure money into private
companies who get rich and who threaten
our environment we should be putting it
into composting and and
Recycling and we should be working back
to the
manufacturers I don't know I don't know
about you but when you go to McDonald's
or you go to Dunkin Donuts and you order
something you get a plastic Cup 14
spoons a bunch of napkins you walk four
feet and you throw it in the trash and
guess where that goes that goes to a
landfill so I I I'm encouraged by where
we
are the the absolute elephant in the
room in any of these conversations is
out of state waste it dwarfs anything
else we do if we want to meet that Solid
Waste plan there's two things we got to
do take the food waste out and and scale
our composting
capability and I'm not saying eliminate
out of state waste but why can't we cut
it in
half and one way to do that is don't
license a new permit to a private
operator who is on record to say that
50% of that waste is going to come from
out of
state it makes no sense
Governor aot went to our little Lake in
the northern part of this state and in 5
minutes took a selfie and she said this
she looked around and said this makes no
sense and to her to her credit she stood
up and doubled down during her
inauguration speech and said there will
be no landfill at Forest
Lake it's a beautiful
place and we're not going to let it
become The Dumping Ground of New England
in order for that to really happen we
need our legislators to be bold and be
courageous and stand up to the interests
of industry and do the right thing for
the people of New Hampshire this is an
issue that's been going on for far too
long and it's not okay to just just punt
it down the the road we have a great
opportunity the moratorium is is a
perfect opportunity to fix a bunch of
things that are
broken and I think that's out of state
ways I think that's leate that we talked
about earlier today I think it's Pas and
I think it's around our site selection
process we have a bunch of things people
are working hard the de Dees is doing
everything they can but they're limited
and they need your help this is a policy
decision and if we can only stand up and
say what we're doing isn't working we
need to go in another Direction let's
take a pause and let's fix this let's
not be The Whipping Boy for
Massachusetts any longer thank you any
questions from the
committee thank you thank you so much
I'd like to call Nicole um donon is it
donon oh Dylan I'm sorry I couldn't read
it d i l l o n and you are from
Lancaster thank
you please put the mic on just yep don't
be nervous there's a button there yep
there you go okay okay we don't bite
we're good
okay I am here to share my story and to
advocate for Forest Lake Bethlehem has
saved my life I came up from
Massachusetts where I lived in a toxic
luxury apartment complex and I got very
very sick from gases there that
were um produced a lot from the leachate
that that happened from the land that
was contaminated that wasn't being
supervised and what happened was um what
I'm asking you I wrote my little notes
here um I'm asking you to support this
bill in the temporary moratorium while
proper supervision regulation and
enforcement is
established I moved up to New Hampshire
from Massachusetts Live Free or Die is
no joke my former luxury apartment
complex was built on contaminated land
and tested by sandborn head who
concluded an exemption to not report
concentrations of hazardous chemicals
including Le
arsonate at that time there was no
significant risk defined by the mCP to
no fault of sandborn heads I'm also
speaking to advocate for them and the
corporations because of the negligence
and the lack of inspections is going to
tarnish their good name their hard work
and dedication trying to figure out how
to manage the
waste at that time there's no
significant risk because there was no
development in comes the property the
luxury apartment
complex that began to suffer corrosion
from being built on the lead arsonate so
all the pipes all the wiring inside the
building inside the walls are corroding
and producing very toxic
gases which is not inspected because
nobody's claiming responsibility for
these properties I shouldn't say these
this one particular property is all I
know for
sure it's an orphan building and no
plumbing inspection nobody knows whose
jurisdiction it
is and there's no supervision or
regulation
so what happens is there's plenty of
water intrusion the sprinkler system is
corroded so there's water pouring
through the ceilings the last year I was
there I had 15 leaks in one year I had
leaks all six years that I was there so
this contaminated water is recycling
inside of the building breaking down
HVAC systems leaking all over the rugs
so when I heard him say
rugs it put a little light bulb off in
my head like those rugs are going into
the dumpsters that are laed with
cassella and we're also downhill from a
super fun site where there's no drainage
on the property because it's saturated
in oil so when the water does finally
subside you can see over by the
playground there's a white residue
that's left on the
grass so I can't say for sure where all
of this trash is going but I do know
that there are Cassel the dumpsters
there and I do see maintenance putting a
lot of items in there that are
questionable I used to be um a special
ed science teacher so I know a little
bit about chemicals and gases I became
too sick and my cognitive ability is out
the window to be able to teach
again it's a miracle I can speak right
now I was having seizures and Comas in
my
apartment so what I'm asking you again
is to consider seriously consider a
temporary moratorium again it's also for
the corporations who did their best they
found an exemption that's their business
that's what they're doing it's okay
there's nothing wrong with it that's
what they did there was no followup
there was no supervision there's no
enforcement there's no checking the
building commissioner's
license there's no one checking up on
the fire department
which is not to their fault they're all
their hands are tied behind their back
and nobody can do anything it's out of
hand so if we have a moratorium and a
little bit more time and some more talk
around the table to say how can we help
everybody and how can we bring Justice
for everybody all around from T tenants
residences and maybe things like streams
that are public water supplies that are
behind luxury apartment complexes like
this that are are contaminating our
society and our
children we just need to talk about it
we need to get the word out and we all
need to communicate what we have here is
a problem of
communication and everybody's at
different levels of
understanding
um I think that's all I again I want to
say I am speaking for the people but
also for the corporations and the
businesses to keep their good name
polished thank you very much for your
testimony any
questions thank you thank you thank you
for your service and uh I only have one
last pin card that's uh director whims
from New Hampshire
Dees
okay good afternoon Madame chair and
members of the committee uh for the
record my name is Mike winsat I serve as
director of the waste management
division for New Hampshire Dees and uh
um the agency is not taking position on
this bill um as we often do we we do
review the bill and uh if we identify
any concerns or observations we we try
to share those with the committee if we
think they're important for the
committee to know about so there are a
handful of things I'd like to review uh
largely technical issues that you know I
think might have an an inadvertent or
not work the way that the sponsor may
have
intended and the first one I'll just go
through the bill it's a pretty short
bill on lines five and six where it
talks about um Department accepting
applications but not um being prohibited
from evaluating or processing them um a
technicality here is that under current
law if um the agency accepts an
application and does not act on it and
and render a decision within a certain
number of days then under RSA 54 31
a29 the application is deemed approved
and I don't think that was the sponsor's
intention here so perhaps a way to
address that would be either to um tell
the agency it has to deny an application
during this period um or um it could say
something like notwithstanding RSA 541
a29 you know and then talk about us not
us being the agency being prohibited
from processing the application so I
just wanted to point that out um um and
then on uh line six again that's that
same provision there um with the
prohibition if the committee is
interested in addressing some of the
concerns have been raised about you know
a delay in reviewing applications may be
potentially causing a capacity problem
then I think that possibly the bill
could instead say something like um the
agency can still process the application
they can engage with the applic to do
some review for completeness and
determine whether you know at least
there's enough information there to to
to process the application during that
moratorium period so that when the
moratorium expires it won't be like
starting from the beginning because as
as I read the language now we can accept
an application but we can't even really
review it or process it in any fashion
and so again that's maybe more of a
technicality than a than anything else
but I want
we thought it was important to raise
that um also on lines seven and eight
um and there's been some testimony about
this it seems to anticipate that
potentially new regulations or new
technologies may come along during this
moratorium period but as I as we read it
this bill doesn't provide for that
necessarily it assumes that those things
are going to happen I guess pursuant to
other legislation or what have you and
it occurs that the concern would be and
I don't know if this is really a concern
that's realistic but if if just this
bill were to pass and then nothing
happened for during that moratorium
period we would then have an application
or we could then receive applications
again and review them under the very
same regime that we have right now and I
don't think that's the the intent of the
sponsor so one thought about that would
be either to include in this bill some
provision for making policy changes
or including Provisions like this
moratorium in another build that seeks
to make changes to to the the regulatory
framework so that's just an
observation and and then on lines 9
through 12 um where it talks about
um the the nothing that that the that
the moratorium doesn't apply to
expansions there's a technical problem
there because it talks about um uh fully
permitted facilities you know it
wouldn't prohibit us from processing
facilities have already been fully
permitted um for an expansion but the
reality is because we administer the
program through a system of permits um
any expansion that may we we may have we
may have already approved an expansion
but it's not fully permitted because it
has to go through design review and
construction approval operating approval
so a technicality in reading that you
could say well your expansion was
approved but it wasn't actually fully
permitted so you can't build it I'm not
sure that again is what is intended by
the legislation so I raised that as a
potential technical problem and then
um I guess the next last of all um on
line 15 of the bill where it makes
reference to
um uh Public Utilities or rather
perennial water bodies transversing
traversing of per of the footprint of
the landfill I'm not really sure how or
where a perennial water body would be
traversing the footprint print ofal
landfill so I'm not I we wouldn't be
permitting something like that so I'm
not sure I'm not really sure where
that's going and I I I don't have a
suggestion for how to fix it because I'm
not really sure why it's there so I just
wanted to raise that because we're not
really understanding what that is and
with that I'm I'm happy to take any
questions okay representative
grber uh director thank you very much
these are very very valuable thoughts
and and comments uh can we get uh a copy
of these in writing or sit down with you
and and discuss how these would work
specifically we're happy to do that we
can I can summarize them in a in a
letter and then uh and provide that to
the committee and to the sponsor great
you thanks very much representative
Penza thank you madam chair and thank
you for your testimony um Mr whims I
think that your first two points were
right on and I appreciate the feedback
on the bill in regards with lines 9
through 12 I think that there's a piece
that is missing it it's talking about
the landfill that is currently fly
permanent nothing to do with the
expansion so I think that that's just a
and I I think it's Crystal Clear there
so
I'm they're not it's not talking about a
permanent expansion it's talking about
it doesn't apply for an operating fully
permitted site
so I I I think I understand what you're
saying I guess my only concern would be
the the fully
permitted
um language is is potentially a little
problematic because at some level maybe
no landfill is ever fully permitted it's
it's an ongoing evolving um regulatory
framework and pretty much if you change
your operating plan it's a permanent
modification so and I'm I'm not trying
to be difficult with that what I'm
saying is if I see the here's the
example let's say that the committee
passes the bill and they expect that any
existing land Fields can be expanded and
aren't infected by the moratorium and
then someone in uh a a location where
that a Landfield is going to be expanded
doesn't like it they may point to that
and say well it's not really fully
permitted so you're subject to the
moratorium and all I'm suggesting is if
that's not the intent of the legislature
when it if it if it advances a bill like
this we want to make sure that that
language is really clear and accurate
doesn't create that kind of a problem
perfect thank you so much welcome okay
representative Bixby so thank you for
for pointing out um this this set of
technical issues um and would it be
correct to assume that you would be
available to the committee or
subcommittee to work on an amendment
that would help iron these out we always
try to be available for technical
assistance whenever it's requested thank
you absolutely okay any other questions
from the
committee thank you very very much for
your uh testimony and and some
Illuminating thoughts and uh uh ideas on
how to improve this bill uh we really
appreciate your time you're welcome
thank you thank you so much
um uh last pin card that I have and we
are sort of running out of time here um
is Jared Sullivan
believe from Grafton 2 representative
good
afternoon thank you madam chair for
having me um I'm actually presenting the
next bill so I can sit here after I'm
done talking um uh yeah anyway so I I
just you're talking about h 171 171 yes
so I just wanted to say uh I support
this bill I come from Bethlehem where as
we know one of the landfills is and
where the location of one of the
controversial potential sites of a new
landfill is going to be adjacent to our
town uh right on our border so uh I I
think this is a great idea moving
forward to try to give us a little bit
of time this has been a contentious
issue in our state for years now um
since before I was in the legislature
and I think uh some of the some of the
um suggestions and the wording that was
just made uh
previously um maybe can be worked into
making this a little bit better but I
think all in all this is something that
we should support we need to take a
little time to make sure we get our
regulations um more modernized with
respect to landfill sighting and I hope
that the committee will take time to to
pass this reg legislation to give us a
chance to do that um you know so that we
don't have a landfill crunch in the
future we have a little bit of Runway
and I think we should not dump the gun
and and approve things before we really
need to and potentially put them in
places that we will uh that people in
future Generations will be regretting so
thank you any questions from the
committee seeing none thank you very
much I appreciate your uh time and uh
can I have the blue sheet for HB
171 um and also want to report
that for this particular Bill the uh
online support was
292 in support of this legislation six
people in opposition on our blue sheet
we have eight
people uh in support of this bill and
with that I'm going to close the hearing
for HB
171 um we are about 20 minutes out or 18
minutes out from uh our our
hr13 but we've all been sitting here for
quite a while and I wonder if anybody
needs a a bio break here for like three
minutes get
out no we cannot do that no no so we
either start the bill or just take a
quick
break yeah and we're we're p yeah so we
want to take a quick break because
people have been waiting here for okay
just few a few minutes if you need to go
visit the restroom and then come
back thank you
in
e
e e
I'd like our members to please take
their seats if there's anyone out in the
hallway please come in and uh we will
resume with uh the last hearing of the
day is everyone here all
right I am going to open the hearing for
hr13 opposing the permitting of a
landfill next to Forest Lake State Park
in Dalton New Hampshire and I uh leave
it to representative Sullivan to
introduce this Bill thank you thank you
madam chair
um so I decided to put in this house
resolution because I think there's been
so much drama around citing of this
specific landfill and as everybody in
this committee is well aware there's a
lot of there's been a lot of uh
animosity and there's been a lot of
arguing there's been a lot of
controversy All Surrounded surrounding
uh landfill sighting in this in this
state our laws I think have been proven
to be a little bit outdated and that's
something that we need time as some of
the other bills that we've us today are
are trying to address but they're a
little bit outdated and we need time to
uh come up with better regulations
around the sighting of landfills but one
thing I think is not controversial at
least it's not controversial to me and I
honestly I don't think it's
controversial to to the majority of
people I speak to if you look at the rep
uh the representatives as co-sponsors
this is a very bipartisan
co-sponsorship is Forest Lake the Forest
Lake location is not a good location for
a landfill the soil there right is very
porous as I'm sure many of you have
heard in other testimonies throughout
the years if you've served on this
committee before or have been paying
attention to the The Saga of this
specific landfill for the past uh many
years it's it's just not a great
location in terms of um if things start
leaking it would go into Forest Lake or
into the adjacent river system which
feeds into the Connecticut I
think it's it's a very reasonable stance
while this has I acknowledge I
acknowledge has no teeth it's just our
our stance as a as a body if we were to
pass this through the house I think it
sends a strong message that this is
something that is is not a good it's not
a good idea to have something next to a
a lake um in in the Hampshire's first
state park that has Lake and if we could
pass this I think that would um help get
us a little bit of of news coverage for
the rest of the state a lot of times up
north where I'm from and where a few
members on this committee are from
we sort of sometimes feel like we're
ignored by people in the South where the
population is and and this this bill is
kind of risen above that or sorry this
issue is risen above that this this
landfill on at Forest Lake I think this
resolution would just elevate it that
much further and bring this this
controversial issue to the mainstream
even more than it already has been
through the great advocacy of many of
the people who've been opposing this for
years and it would hopefully help really
solid solidify um the the position of
the state that this is not a good place
for this and we need to hold off on
putting a landfill in one of the more
beautiful parts of our state that is
potentially dangerous if there's leaking
and because of all the uh hydrology of
the soil in the area of that area of
that location and give us some more time
to find better locations and and better
regulations so um that's the motivation
behind this and I really hope that you
guys will um consider this and hopefully
we can in a in a few weeks time be
celebrating passage on the
house any questions from the
committee um I do have a quick question
actually
um seeing as uh house house resolutions
like kind of don't go anywhere they
don't go to the well they the Senate
never does anything with them um how do
you feel that this is um you
know meaningful to do
yeah so and and I as I said when I was
presenting this I think that I I
acknowledge that there's no teeth to a
house resolution but what it does is it
shows this is the position of the house
and that should Elevate this issue
Statewide because that will get covered
in the media that'll show that the
majority of the house and that would be
a
bipartisan vote if if we can pass this
the majority of people in the house
regardless of party do not want this
landfill think this is an inappropriate
site for a landfill is there teeth
behind it no and I acknowledge that
there isn't but I think elevating this
issue and showing that there's a
bipartisan support something that we can
all unite behind is a great message for
the people of New Hampshire because
increasingly it's rare that we see
bipartisan work and when when we do see
it the citizens celebrate that they love
that and B it would also just Elevate
this issue for the people who live in
the southern part of the state whether
it's Portsmith or nashor Manchester a
lot of these people don't actually
understand some of the issues going on
with to this bill and so this would just
get a little bit more news coverage and
you know we all know a lot of people a
lot of our constituents are living in
bubbles they're not always paying
attention to issues that are not in
their backyards and you there's not a
lot of people up in this part of the
state and so this is a good way for us
to sort of magnify an issue that's
really important to us and should be
important to them do you feel that um
the issue of citing a landfill in dalon
has not gotten enough
press no I'm I'm I think it's done
they've done a great job The Advocate
advocates for it have done a great job
in uh elevating it but I think that this
would be a way to elevate it even more
because it would it sent a message that
this is the official position of the
house if if this were to pass this would
be the official position of the house
and I think that that would that would
be a statement and it's own right that
would be
newsworthy okay thank you representative
ger and representative wheeler if you
need to sit you may please go to your
seat thank you madam chair thank you
representative Sullivan um would you you
say that a a house resolution in
addition to the statement that has been
made by the governor provides added
added weight does it mean more for a
house resolution on this issue do you
think to pass given the statement that
the governor's already made and does
that perhaps also send a message to the
body on the other side of the wall uh if
future action uh is required yeah I mean
I think if two of the three um branches
of of of government
are in in in in uh are ear in agreement
on this then I mean that's a pretty
powerful statement and you know the
government has been pretty clear on this
and if we are clear about it then it's
hard to imagine that um the the people
on the other side of the of the wall are
going to Buck that Trend sorry I didn't
give you that thank you any other
questions from the committee uh
representative wheeler I have a question
for you madam chair um is the house
resolution able you put on the consent
calendar I don't
know I would imagine it should I I will
ask that question of our uh house clerk
I I believe it is but that would be a
question for the committee
to I believe that a house resolution can
be on the consent calendar but given
that the idea behind a house resolution
is to make a point about something
public it might make sense sense not to
put it on the consent calendar and just
have a and even if we all agree on it
have a a brief speech at the well saying
this is um this is a great idea let's
all support
it okay well does a resolution need a
simple majority in the house do we know
that I thought it needed more than a
simple majority in which case it
couldn't go on consent is it simple I'm
not sure for that
either um but I do
know par pardon me do you mind if I
leave at there's a question for me I
have to go to work sure than sure
there's no questions for you um but I
but I do know that there are a fair
amount of house reps that will not
support house resolutions because they
don't feel that they are meaningful at
all so there's that I'm just just
saying uh I call Carolyn
Cho to speak on hr13
good afternoon thanks for hanging in
there and put on yeah there you
go I'm here to uh I am Carolyn from NASA
I'm here to put a human face uh on the
issue um I'm a member of the cancer Club
anyone else here a member of that
club
um not once but twice and
uh I am 67 now and my first bout was at
45 with breast cancer and told I had
three years to live and then 20 years
later um thyroid cancer and I took a a
moral
obligation way back when as a 45y old
with two very young children that uh I
would do whatever
I
could uh to
prevent cancer in all its forms to the
best of my knowledge and I was a TV
reporter for 30 years at tv13 Nasa that
I owned with my husband Gordon and I
spent many an hour up here in conquer so
I know all about the media and uh we do
care in Southern New Hampshire about
this Lake and we do care about or I care
about all the different causes of
cancer my last Bel with cancer was
thyroid and uh
PFS are a definite cause I now uh spend
my time between working full-time at
Southern New Hampshire
University and writing
about uh epigenetic forms of diet and
all the different ways that cancer is
making its way into our lives and just
happens that my column this week is
about PFS and all the
ways it is working its way into our
lives I would vouch to say that we're
consuming it all in our water every day
because unless you're drinking uh
reverse osmosis water
you are consuming
PFS every day everything you eat
everything you drink Everything You
Touch
and to think that there is yet this
beautiful little piece of
property uh indeed the first state park
when I found out that someone
was I don't know if I want to say crazy
enough or
um ambitious
enough um to take advantage of
our Live Free or Die sort of uh
libertarianism
um knowing that cassella does even
mention on its website about its support
and idealism ideology for sustainability
I really had to shake my head because I
thought at what price
so I
uh drove up to Dalton and
I I don't know how many nashin have done
that but I did because I wanted to know
firsthand what are these people facing
and
why um and and is anyone listening
I'm
nobody but I'm a New Hampshire resident
I'm someone who um feels like it is my
backyard
and
I don't know how many of my neighbors
took off or felt like they could take
off work today to come up here but by
golly I think I represent a lot of
people who give a damn about this
and I hope someone is listening so I
was uh listening to your parliamentary
procedure
observations and I hope that you
will recall this conversation here
that I hope there yes is
bipartisan uh belief in this cause I'm
so glad that Governor aot is behind this
cause uh please know that I think that I
speak on behalf of a lot of people who
don't
want this landfill there my
husband helped me write a little diddy
last night for our Lake sake dump the
dump I mean it's just really a
no-brainer and I do seriously hope we
don't let
um don't let the
financial um
proclivities of Private Industry get in
the way of what this small
community wants and needs as it
represents all of us
and I don't know what questions you
might want to ask me but I'll be happy
to answer
them thank you for your testimony this
afternoon and um I appreciate your
experience on this I certainly do not
think that you're a nobody you are
somebody who've come forward to talk to
us and and tell us your story and we do
really appreciate that that you've taken
the time
and the energy to do that uh
representative
Penza yeah um thank you madam chair and
ditto to what representative Aaron was
going to say you're not a nobody you're
actually a constituent you're our boss
and uh and your voice is just as strong
as the other you know 1.4 or 13999
million in New Hampshire so um we're
supposed to take direction from you and
I'm so glad that you came here sorry it
wasn't a question
um would you know that you're very
important to
us well you know like I did I like to
say as a cancer survivor flat but
beautiful thank you and I do hope you
will above all truly pay attention uh
I'm sorry that the paaf law did not go
as far as I had hoped it would but uh
get your all get yourselves a filtration
CH system for your homes and our and our
capital
thank you I call Nancy Morrison oh yeah
thank you I call Nancy
Morrison Well hello again and thank you
for hearing my testimony today I'm Nancy
Morrison from Whitefield New
Hampshire and uh I bring greetings to
chairwoman Judy Aon and the esteemed
members of this
committee I'm here today to ask you to
vote Yes on house resolution
13 to keep a landfill from being built
next to Forest Lake State Park one of
New Hampshire's 10 original
parks there are actually 93 state parks
in total in New Hampshire and they all
deserve protection from projects that
would threaten their natural resources
and Beauty as well as endanger public
health and harm our tourism industry
which drives New Hampshire's
economy however only one of these 93
state parks is being threatened by the
construction of a mega landfill with the
potential to occupy over time
up to
1,800 Greenfield Acres including all its
infrastructure a mountain of trash
admittedly 50% from out of state would
be situated on porest Sand and Gravel
next to the pristine gem Forest Lake as
well as the eMusic River Watershed and
Acres of wetlands and fragile
ecosystems I will not review with all of
you what you have heard about
degradation and dangers of
landfills you've heard enough of that
today but we are talking about the air
we breathe the water we drink and the
soil we grow our food in for generations
to
come and Judy my last sentence kind of
has you in mind from what you said
earlier I know house resolution 13 is a
non-binding
determination but it would stand as a
symbol and as a signal of what New
Hampshire values and is committed to
protecting for its citizens and the
environment
here thank you for your thoughtful
consideration on this
resolution good okay thank you thank you
um you have written testimony to submit
I do I didn't know it was important
enough sure we'd like to include that in
our
file uh call the last pin card unless
anybody else would like to speak U Mr
John Swan from safe Forest Lake
good afternoon Madam chair and members
of the committee thank you for hearing
my
testimony um my name is John Swan I live
in Dalton New Hampshire I do not live on
Forest Lake uh I live near it and use it
um prior uh I I do need to preface my
testimony by stating that in order to
not get sued a third time by cassella I
need you to understand that all of this
is my opinion based on my research
and experience um you know and part of
that it you know it's kind of funny to
have to add that to uh basically my
public statements but
um in April of 2020 uh cassella filed
suit against me for uh claiming 39
statements I made were defamatory and
then uh that basically uh through the
process with the judicial system it was
Whitted down to nine and then ultimately
we wound up settling uh they didn't want
to go to court uh signed a
non-disclosure agreement
and then uh two weeks later that didn't
like the new story that came out in the
Caledonian record about the story and
they filed a second suit against me for
um basically saying I uh I violated the
non-disclosure agreement and since then
the uh uh reporter that did call me I
told him no comment um he uh filed a
deposition stating that he never did
speak with me about the story John
cassella just didn't like the story and
then uh since then theyve amended their
complaint against me to include
uh statements by them saying my my
assertions that the NCS landfill is
contaminating The Watershed of the amonk
river are false and defamatory so um I
think the groundwater reports that they
submit uh via sandborn head
um will uh help that in court we will be
in court in September I believe but uh
it's cost me over approximately $200,000
in legal fees uh so far with all the
lawsuits um but I do want to uh you know
I really can't Nancy's a hard act to
follow I just want to mention that I did
email you my testimony and in that I
included a two-pager it's a for Lake
State part uh GSL landfill info sheet I
hope you'll read it I've gone through I
mean I've I've
spent hours reading all these documents
these
applications and this breaks down the
impacts that this will have on the North
country but I also want to share the
fact that the one thing that has
remained constant um they withdrew the
first set of applications resubmitted
again they had to whittle it down to a
right now they're calling it a one-phase
only 70 acre 18-year landfill the one
thing that's remained constant is
they're seeking
600,000 cubic yards of annual capacity
converted to tonnage at a 78 rate which
is typically used uh it's about 456,000
tons a year um to put that in
perspective the current permit for the
uh stage six um operating permit for the
NCS landfill is
230,000 cubic yards or approximately
180,000 tons a year so in essence
cassella is seeking 2.5 times what
they're currently taking in at the NCS
landfill so just please that's in my in
my uh testimony I sent you it's very
important because they say it's an
18-year landfill however they they have
admitted and in discussions in Dalton
with the select board there that the um
the life of the facility is not over
with until the capacity is is exhausted
so if you take that
230,000 cubic yards that they're
currently doing at Bethlehem roll that
into the 18 years times 600,000 cubic
yards it's approximately 46 years of
permitted life for this facility and
that goes against the wishes or the
intent of RSA 149 M which is calls for
only a 20-year permitting period gives
them a lot of wiggle room because let's
say they do use that 600,000 cubic yards
based on what they're bringing into the
Bethlehem facility 60% of that would be
from out of state so just something to
keep in mind it's giving them a lot of
wiggle room and then of course as Nancy
mentioned they have
1,899 acres of land under contract they
have not closed on that land yet so keep
in mind they they can obviously walk
away from the land deal if they don't
get their permitting which is what
they're waiting for so anyway um thank
you for the long day of testimony and uh
I really hope you'll you'll you'll it's
a symbolic gesture but this is the
people's house I mean we've been coming
to you for six years for help so you
know please I mean there a lot of lives
a lot of families that that couldn't be
here today but their lives their
properties would will be impacted by
this facility so and we really don't
want to lose that Lake it's a beautiful
Lake it's clean there's no posos there
there's no posos on the site property
and there's no posos in our wells that's
why I bring my water everywhere I don't
get ice cubes when I go to a diner I
don't know what's in the water my well
no posos detection so thank you I
appreciate your testimony this afternoon
any questions from the committee seeing
none thank you very much appreciate it
any anyone else wish to speak on this uh
hr13 okay I have the blue sheet and uh
let's just see here I
have for the online testimony we had
296 people in support thank you sir um
in support six of six opposed one
neutral and I have um you
three four eight people in support of
hr13 uh on the blue signup sheet and
with that I'm going to close the hearing
on
hr13 okay and um I do have a little bit
of uh committee housekeeping that I just
want to talk to you guys about um
representative Penza you had a something
to share with the committee yeah I'd
like to make a motion that we can exec
this bill right now um I not comfortable
doing
that one of
the uh one of the Notions behind in
general uh holding off to it for on exec
until uh we can until it's been noticed
in the calendar is that there are people
who may be interested in being there for
the exec session and they need to have
proper warning that it's going to be
coming up so I I think that uh having
that um that is
a as a part of a standard transparency
is is important uh sometimes there is a
bill that is fairly and the one that we
did this afternoon that we did exact
this afternoon uh Judy and I talked
about that um well in advance of uh of
of doing it uh we and we um and uh we
decided that because it was a very
non-controversial
Bill and um would would be served well
by going through quickly uh it would
make sense to exec but usually we are we
we are we will almost always stick to
having a at least the uh normal notice
period for any
exec okay I get it I just um just as a
followup it's not a bill it's a
resolution so we've listen to a lot of
testimony I don't see the necessity of
of having an executive session on it it
it's
it's okay all right representative
Scully you had a question no okay so uh
representative kto you had something you
wanted to share with the committee as
well I do thank you madam chair um as
always the young Farmers would like to
do a breakfast for us uh this year
they'd like to do it at a farm in London
dery and they have given two dates um
March 17th and March 24th and I just
wanted to get a consensus from the
committee which Tuesday would work best
for
folks March when and when March 17th or
March
24th so those are both Mondays are they
Mondays Yeah March 17th well I guess
they're Mondays I thought they were
Tuesdays maybe they they told me those
dates but I told them Tuesday so uh
let's think about March 18th and 25th
also as possible so I'll give them those
one of those two weeks I didn't know
which would be better for
folks for me um well it doesn't
matter okay okay so I have a mo uh
someone yeah right well they were
supposed to give me Tuesday dates so I
will let her know
um and the idea was is so we could get
to committee but obviously in March
we're not going to be having committee
meetings we're going to be having
session so um but they do do a nice
breakfast uh they bring in uh Farm milk
uh bake everything with farm fresh eggs
and uh maple syrup off the the farms and
berries it's it's it's good and uh you
get to learn about what Young farmers
are doing go ahead repres um s represent
B so it is actually conceivable that we
might be doing exex on that on the
earlier date because that's before the
Dead the second deadline of the the
regular Bill deadline uh so um so it
might make more sense to have the
earlier date
um yep are you saying do the breakfast
on lat no no same day and then you come
here same day because if we're doing
exacts it's not going to be we're it's
not going to be a full day of testimony
it's going to be an hour or so here so
we could do the do the breakfast have
our execs at like 10:30 or something and
then be done by
noon okay the other thing I wanted to
bring up to the committee is school
vacation week which is the week of
February
23rd and um as I understand um the house
would request house leadership has
requested uh that we not schu anything
for that week are we all okay with that
yeah I know that there are some people
who are going
away the week of February
24th so I'm not going to schedule any
meetings for
that for that
week that being said I mean we we have a
fair amount of bills to get through
we've got 31 bills in our
committee um and as we've seen uh
several of them are a little
complicated um and some of them have
been taking um you know quite a a while
in committee hearings so we may need to
make one or two times where we're
meeting twice a week instead of once a
week and I kind of want to get an idea
from the committee um what days would be
preferable aside from a
Tuesday uh what days would work best for
the majority of everybody for hearings
or uh I I wouldn't schedule any exec
sessions on that second day but just at
least work sessions and hearings for
those dates so I don't know if Mondays
are better for
people
no Wednesdays are generally Municipal
and County uses the room we could but
there are the rooms available there well
you know could that could be a problem
but I I'll see what we can
do so my preference would be in this
order uh Wednesdays Mondays and last
last uh Resort Fridays okay Madam
chairman I think we spoke earlier today
during lunch there are going to be some
some of those days I will not be able to
make it and I U okay right thank you
yep uh representative comor thank you um
Madam chair Wednesdays would uh be
preferable for me okay all right cool
good to know and representative how also
okay County meetings Monday morning okay
okay all right good to know um okay the
other thing I wanted to get back to you
all regarding some questions uh about
house
resolutions uh I did text our house
clerk Paul Smith I said for house
resolutions can they be on the consent
calendar and he replied yes uh when the
house votes on an HR is a prevailing
vote a simple majority or a higher
threshold and he said simple majority so
so I just wanted to share that with you
all representative wheeler I would
agree I agree with that but I also agree
um uh I think that keeping it off the
consent calendar is a good thing I was
just I was just asking just to clarify
from a procedural standpoint
but I agree I
agree okay
um I as I said I had sent out to
everybody a list of uh where the
subcommittee assignments are and uh as I
as we've decided today there will be um
two bills that are going to a solid
waste
subcommittee and one going to the animal
protection and Licensing subcommittee so
I would hope that you can organize your
meetings as soon as possible and start
discussing them and you can um the the
the the folks on those committees animal
protection and Licensing are kamto as
chair representative Kenny
representative Freeman representative
has Haskins and representative sopi
kitis and then on the solid waste
subcommittee representative King as
chair we have representative Skully
Penza ger and Gruber who are on the
solid waste subcommittee so um as soon
as you guys can meet and sort of hash
out whatever you need to um to either
come up with a new Amendment or
amendments well amendment I hope um for
those bills to kind of clean them up and
see where we can be um that would be
great um I have a proposed schedule of
bills which um already I can see is
going to be changed um
and um I heard
today that the paint recycling bill was
going to be vac ated to our
committee but I but wait wait wait but I
also know that Thursday Commerce is
having a hearing on it that's already
been noticed so I have indicated to
represent uh to us the uh the house
clerk Paul Smith that I choose not to
have that bill vacated to our committee
since Commerce has already scheduled a
hearing and it's an early bill I don't
know where we might be able to fit that
in but um I have to still wait and hear
back from them as to whether or not we
are going to get that bill but um for
now we've got 31 bills in our
committee six of them are early bills um
we have
heard five of
them and we will be hearing one next
week and other than that um Madam chair
what does vacated to our committee that
means that right now that bill was
assigned to Commerce because there were
a lot lot of language in that bill
having to do with retailers and how
they put up signage what kind of fees
they have to collect and so and so
forth vacated to means that it's given
to our committee taken out of that
committee and given to us yeah I I can
just make a quick clarification so if uh
if the if a so the the speaker's office
assigns uh the bills to various
committees based on their best guess of
where it should go and sometimes they
guess wrong okay and the uh chairs of
the committee uh of one committee will
say this shouldn't come to our committee
and a chair of another committee said
that should have come to our committee
if those the typical procedure is that
if the bill has not been noticed in the
calendar those two chairs can agree that
they would like to move the bill from
one count one committee to another and
if the speaker also agrees then that can
happen and that process is called
vacating uh it seems like this the
process did not actually work the way it
should have in for this bill there was
another bill where Judy and I looked at
it and we said this doesn't really
belong on our committee this belongs in
fishing game and and I had that vacated
to fishing game so that was one less on
our plate yeah so that and that one went
the way it was supposed to
right yeah but um I I still have to
check back with the uh house clerk to
see if they can reverse that um vacating
to our committee because um there was a
question about it and I raised that with
um our house speaker and they said they
were going to look at it and I didn't
and I and then when I found out that
they had scheduled a hearing commas had
scheduled a hearing for this Thursday I
contacted the speaker's office and I
said never mind don't bother you know
you've already they've already started
working on this so um but then I got a
notice this morning that that paint
recycling bill was vacated to our
committee and I'm like but no
no another and one of the reasons that
you don't CH do the vacation after uh
it's been noticed
is there is someone who is coming from
California on Thursday to testify on
that bill if it gets vacated then that
that gets you know that screws up that
person who's like coming across the
country in order to speak to it so um so
it does not make sense if once it's been
noticed to uh yeah
yeah so is this like implementation of
the bill because we passed the bill as a
for it to be a pilot project I thought
no no no no okay so um what we did in
this committee we passed the bill
unanimously and then it passed the house
unanimously and then it went to the
Senate and this the senate
committee was leaning in favor of it but
they said let's just check with the
governor and see if the governor is
willing to sign it and the answer came
back no the governor wasn't willing to
sign it so the SE senate committee uh s
it to interim study so that it wouldn't
have the blot of a veto on it gotcha so
it was back and and actually um paint
cares the people who are working on it
they were happy to see that it had um
been stalled because there was still
some work that they needed to do uh with
representative eel so that work is
already been put in this current bill so
this bill is a better
bill um it's just not it's just in it's
not our bill and um so in any case I
just wanted to let the committee know
that that was happening and um and
that's it I guess uh have a have a nice
rest of the evening and rest of the week
and motion to adjourn so a quick one
quick note if uh assuming that it is
still going to be on in Commerce do sign
in remotely or if you're here sign in in
person just in favor of it thanks thank
you appreciate all your time and work on
all these bills thank you